You know the background?
Oh yeah.
Eventually that's what it'll be for
right now.
It's coughing.
This episode of the Joe Rogan Experience
Podcast,
I fucking center.
I set my own name.
I hate doing that.
The podcast.
It's very dueschy.
When someone says their own name,
unless you really have to like someone
asks you what your name is and you go,
my name's Joe Rogan.
Then it's okay,
but if you say it,
especially if someone's tuning into a
podcast as your name on it,
I'm just trying to not be as Douchey is
possible.
Folks.
It's hard.
It's very hard.
This episode of the podcast is brought
to you by stamps.com
stamps.
Dot Com is a way.
If you have a small business or even if
you do things from your office,
it's a way to avoid all the lines at the
post office and send shit directly from
your office,
your home,
wherever you are,
and printing official US postage for any
letter,
any package right from your computer or
printer.
It's very easy to do.
You weigh it.
You hand it to the mailman and with our
special offer using the code word j r e,
you get a free digital scale and up to
$55 of free postage.
It's a glorious deal.
Ladies and gentleman.
It's super easy to do.
It cuts out all the fucking wasted time
that you get.
If you go to the post office and you
could do all this stuff,
print everything up drunk and naked.
A bonus.
One hundred $10 bonus.
Offer no risk trial.
Use The code word J R E and get up to
$55 again of free postage,
so don't wait.
Go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in j r,
e that stamps dot Com and type in j r,
e dot.
We're also brought to you by one 800
flowers.
It's mother's Day freaks.
It's right around the corner.
Was it the Sunday?
Yes.
It's always the Sunday,
right?
It's always on Sunday's mother's Day was
on Sunday.
Should be suck.
If your mom had mother's Day,
that was on Tuesday,
that would be some bullshit.
Mother's deserve credit.
They deserve respect.
Without them,
you would not be alive.
Ladies and gentlemen,
your mother gave birth to you.
Deal with that and go to one 800
flowers.com.
Scrape up some sheckles with the shackle
worth.
Tim Kennedy or worldly man with a shekel
Uh,
I have no idea.
This is a shackled to dollar ratio.
I just know it has something to do with
Jews.
You got to be careful when you shekel.
Jews are very touchy anyway.
Available only Thursday,
May 8th through Thursday,
May 8th,
which is tomorrow.
One 800 flowers.com
has a special mother's day offer.
For my listeners throwing my listeners,
but you know,
I'm talking about 24 beautiful
multicolored roses for just 29 99.
That's a full bouquet of two dozen
stunning roses and you can't beat this
offer regularly.
It's $49.
Ninety nine now,
only 29 99.
You save 20 bucks,
but you gotta order it soon because it
expires on Thursday,
May 8th.
So hurry ordered today and available
while supplies last.
To get this bouquet delivered in time
for mother's Day,
you must go to one 800 flowers.com
from your desktop or mobile device.
Click on the radio microphone in the
upper right hand corner and enter inj r
e,
that's one 800 flowers.com.
And enter in J R E or call one 800
flowers dot Com and mention j r e m.
I'm going to get them to my mom,
but I got to wait because my mom's in
Mexico.
My mom is moving to Mexico.
Crazy bitch.
It's just crazy.
I mean bitch,
with all due respect,
I call myself a bitch.
Call everybody a bitch.
I don't really mean like a female dog or
a a bad person.
I mean if you're really thinking about
moving to Mexico,
you're fucking crazy.
Anyway,
Mother's Day go one 800 flowers.com.
Use the code word jre and save yourself
some money and hook your mom up.
She'll be happy.
If you did,
were also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
That's o n n I t official sponsor of Tim
Kennedy.
We gotta figure out a way to sponsor
fight is actually in the UFC.
The UFC has a,
there's a Mussel farm monopoly right
now.
We have to break that.
I don't care.
I wouldn't care if it was actually good
products,
but muscle farm is not.
I don't think so.
I've never used it with protein powders
and stuff like plastic that fills your
stomach up.
I don't know what his muscle farm.
They make all the typical,
you know,
the pre workout,
post workouts,
proteins,
toilet stuff,
you know,
like Jack's,
your heart rate up to one 80 before your
workout and then afterwards when it
supposedly it tastes good.
It's just full of sugar.
I know.
I've never had a good experience with a
single muscle farm product.
Obviously.
I like on it.
Whoa.
Tim Kennedy just laid down the law.
How rude.
Um,
I have nothing bad to say.
I'm about farm.
I have no relationship with them.
I have no experience with them,
but I do have a deep,
long and storied experience with on it.
Uh,
our protein powder is 100 percent
natural and also 100 percent sugar free.
The only sugar is one gram of sugar,
which is naturally occurring per
serving.
That comes from the hemp.
I have to answer this,
I have to say this every episode,
but just because I get asked all the
time,
if you eat him,
you will not test positive for
marijuana.
Hemp does not have any thc in it.
But again,
if you read poppy seed Bagels,
you will test positive for heroin.
It sounds crazy,
but it's totally true.
Hemp force,
we use the finest available protein
powder that we can buy,
which we have to buy from Canada because
the laws are fucking goofy in America
and we're not allowed to grow hemp.
We can buy it,
but we can't support American farmers,
which drives me fucking crazy.
Hopefully laws have been changed and
hopefully soon we will be able to
support farmers and by our own when
we're supporting Canadian farmers,
but we'll hopefully be able to support
American farmers and maybe even get our
own hemp farm.
Right now though.
It's a little too sketchy and I don't
want to go to jail,
so we buy it and then we sell it.
We sell the best shit that we can find,
whether it's strength and conditioning
equipment.
We sell a need,
just the finest kettlebells and steel
maces and clubs,
weight vest.
If we find something and it's good,
we find something.
It's beneficial,
whether it's a supplement or a food.
We sell it and we try to get it at the
most reasonable rates possible and we
find the best quality stuff.
Whatever it is,
whether it's the best quality protein
powders,
where's the best quality walnut,
almond cashew butter,
anything we sell raw organic coconut
oil.
We just try to sell the best shape
available and we try to sell it to you
as cheaply as possible.
If you use the code name Rogan,
you will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
Tim Kennedy is here.
Let's cue the music.
Why fuck around
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Jim Kennedy,
ladies and Gentlemen,
I've been wanting to talk to you for
awhile.
Dude,
you're an interesting cat.
You've been around the world saying that
you laughing like you're not.
Nope.
No,
I'm not laughing that I'm,
I'm,
uh,
interesting.
Uh,
but I had wanted to talk to you in the
octagon for a really long time.
So we took a while.
It didn't take long time like wow,
12 years as a pro to finally get a
little
Jill interview.
But the interview was a,
you couldn't ask for a better
environment to do that first interview,
do it when the UFC fight for the troops,
you know,
to do it and do it after that
spectacular knockout.
And that was intense man and it,
it wasn't just intense because you won.
What was really intense for me is,
um,
and I've always experienced this in
these fights for the troops.
First of all,
it's great to be able to go to them and
put on these fights and have them in
these hangers and that these tight
environments and just the appreciation
and the respect that everybody has for
the fighters is really intense.
But you eat,
first of all,
you being a veteran and you,
you being unabashed in your love for
soldiers and your respect for your,
your,
your fellow military members.
When you got on top of that cage and
after,
you know,
they were all cheering and you were
yelling out to all those people that you
love them.
I mean this is all off camera,
man.
We'd cut to commercial and you're on top
of the cage and you're just yelling and
all those people letting them know that
you loved them.
That was some intense,
intense shit.
Yeah.
Overwhelming emotional near shutdown.
I'm walking out to the cage.
I see this dude.
He flies for the one 60th,
which is like the special forces wing of
aviation.
The last time I saw that dude was
handing him my shot buddy.
You know,
I'm like,
it's a big thing in special forces
community.
We're real tight,
you know,
like I'm handing him my brother that has
bullet holes in him and I'm a.
and I'm like,
I don't wanna let him go.
And he's like,
Hey,
I got this.
This is what I do.
You go do what you're supposed to do and
get back to work.
That was the last time I saw this dude
was handing him my buddy on a medivac.
Then I'm walking out of the cage and I
was like,
Holy Shit.
There is that dude from the 68 that I
handed my shot buddy to totally
overwhelming.
They have to go in there and fight.
And then uh,
you know,
Nice.
Fifth Special Forces group is co located
there.
So I saw a bunch of dudes from like the
Green Brae regiment.
That was entirely too much emotion.
I just wanted to curl up and cry.
Yeah,
it's a completely different kind of.
There's you on top of the cage up there
in that photo.
That's just an intense,
intense picture.
That picture should be framed and on
your wall somewhere because that is one
of the greatest pictures have ever seen.
Have you could cut me out and just have
the dudes,
Nah,
Nah.
You need to be in there for reference.
I mean,
but that's your attitude.
What you just said,
cut me out and leave the dudes that
there really is your attitude.
You really don't want that.
You were saying while you were up there
that my job is,
is in here is easy.
What you guys do.
You guys are my heroes.
You good memory?
Yeah.
I remember everything.
It's disturbing.
Scary.
Don't get in a fight with Joe Rogan
verbally not go well for you.
I remember things well.
I remember important things and that was
a,
that was a deep moment.
You know,
there was um,
I wrote a thing a long time ago about,
uh,
one of the fights for the troops about
the,
uh,
the national anthem.
And I recorded it.
I filmed it on my phone when someone was
singing the national anthem and you turn
around and you know,
I was filming the crowd while it was all
going on and the feeling the air,
the electricity in the air of hearing
the national anthem while you were
around.
Active duty soldiers who are in a war
currently have had friends who had loved
ones die,
have experienced firefights have been
there if comeback.
And now they're here in time off getting
to enjoy a fight.
And everyone's standing up in this whole
tricity in the air.
Man,
you're fucking.
EHRS are standing up on your back.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's intense.
It's intense.
Two totally different experience.
It's there.
I don't know.
I don't understand the whole realm
outside of like what you can physically
see,
but there is no way to describe,
you know,
like moments like that where you're
surrounded by these heroes that these
selfless freaking superstars of humanity
and um,
you know,
they bleed in every sense of the word
for their country.
And then the national anthem,
Kamala and,
or the flag goes up and you see them all
and there,
there's,
there's this energy there that just
can't be described.
It can only be experienced.
It's surreal,
you know,
that's the,
that's the really intense,
uh,
aspect of it is that there's,
there's a lot of resistance and blow
back towards war and towards the
military industrial complex and towards,
both of which are horrible.
Yeah.
But what the,
what's important is the people ever.
Everybody wants everything to be black
and white and there's no black and white
in this world.
There's this gigantic of shades and
there's.
There's positive and there's negative,
there's good and there's bad,
but there are real heroes in the world.
I'm Pat Tillman is a perfect example of
a guy who was a real hero in my opinion.
A guy who saw what was going on and
said,
you know what?
Fuck this NFL career.
I don't need millions of dollars when I
needed to do is do what's right and I
need to fight for my country.
He goes over there and then when he gets
there,
he experienced chaos and nonsense and
he's super vocal about it and completely
as is his brother and that's to me a
perfect example of that.
There is no black and white.
There's a lot of.
There's real heroes.
There's people that have heroic content
and there's people that have heroic
ideals and they really do love and
respect the idea of freedom,
but they get thrust into a situation
where everything is completely out of
control and chaotic and a garlic.
Pat Tillman was very vocal about it and
well spoken,
very well spoken as is his brother,
you know,
it's,
it's a very intense thing and when,
you know,
people were anti war and you know,
it's,
it's Kinda,
it's fashionable to be anti war,
you know,
it's a thing that a lot of people put
on,
like an outfit.
They just sort of jump into the
sentiment that we shouldn't have a
military and we shouldn't have wore.
The real problem is human beings are
still animals and a lot of research,
a lot of respects,
a lot of senses and probably nobody
knows that more than a guy like you
who's been there.
War is horrible.
I hate war.
I am anti war.
I've been anti war my whole entire life
with,
you know,
uncles that fought in world war two or
in Vietnam,
you know,
grandparents that fought in world war
two.
Um,
but with that position of being anti
war,
I don't think you should be able to be
anti war unless you understand at a
fundamental level how awful and horrible
war is not.
That doesn't mean they have to go and
serve.
But,
um,
it's necessary,
you know,
it's,
um,
I don't,
I wouldn't wish what I've seen in my
life on my worst enemy,
you know,
there's no way I'd want the people.
I hate to have to see know what a little
girl looks like when she's been,
had acid thrown on her because she tried
to go to school.
I want that,
want that on my worst enemy.
But,
um,
there's people that do those things,
you know,
there's people that go and kidnap 300
girls in school this week because they
were going to school,
you know,
those people don't.
They have to answer to somebody and the
only people they would answer to or guys
like me or guys that are better than me
that are still doing it.
And uh,
and it's a necessary evil.
You know,
you fight fire with fire,
you fight evil with just a more violent,
better version of evil,
which is,
that's a crazy way to look at the world.
But in a lot of respects,
there's no other options.
And in some situations there are no
other options unless you let evil,
overwhelming area or evil overwhelm a
group of innocent people.
There's almost no.
And to denied the existence of evil is
completely fucking ridiculous.
Especially if you just look at human
history,
look at human history from recorded
times,
from the beginning when people started
writing things down.
People always did awful shit.
If they could get away
to get away from,
get away with it.
For evil to prevail all it takes us for
good men to do nothing.
Right?
So great quote.
Yeah.
Just have to do something even if it's
horrible.
How long were you over there for?
I was eight years active duty,
um,
special forces.
And now it's been three years as a
national guardsman in special forces.
And how old are you now?
Thirty four.
So wow.
So you were really young,
so you're,
you're essentially like college age?
Yeah,
as soon as I was in Grad school when I
enlisted.
And how old were you then?
I was 22.
Wow.
So you,
you saw what was going on and you just
decided that this was calling you.
It was a balance.
It was like the perfect storm for me,
for me to go in.
I was,
I was kind of,
this was before it.
We'll call,
we'll call it pro.
I was a pro MMA fighter and I had five
fights as foreign one,
you know,
I just won this ECC,
50 big eight men tournament,
you know,
Jason Miller,
Dennis Kang,
myself,
we're all in it.
And I was the one that won it.
So like I had good promise.
Um,
I was a Douche bag.
I was a little idiot in San Luis Obispo.
We know with the entire,
the Mecca of fighting at the time.
I'm like worrying about what genes I was
going to wear to the next party,
you know,
like,
oh,
I want to with my next winnings from
this fight,
I'm going to go buy these something
stupid.
Did you have genes that are already
ripped?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Can I pay way too much for really crappy
genes?
That looks cool.
Anyways,
so make it a lot of poor decisions.
And,
you know,
nine slash 11 happened and it was just
one of those instances that's a godsend.
Divine intervention may be where you get
this extra central perspective of how
much of an idiot you are.
And that's what I had.
I was like,
God,
I am really one of the worst people on
the planet.
Um,
you know,
not being a productive,
contributing member to society in any
way,
just being a succubus of life.
And so I walked down after nine slash 11
to the recruiter's office and the pro,
I wish I could just knock on the door,
but that wasn't the issue.
The issue was that there was like a
thousand other dudes in line ahead of me
that I wanted to do the same thing.
And just to give you a testament about
how amazing the backbone of our country
still is.
What was that feeling like when you
showed up and you see a thousand other
that are wrapping around the supermarket
have the same mentality?
How humbling,
you know,
we're like,
again,
I'm still still a little fucked hard,
you know?
Um,
I was like,
thinking us,
I'm going to go enlist,
you know,
when I get down there,
I was like,
man,
I should've been here like five hours
ago,
you know,
and uh,
instance after instance.
Yeah,
it cool.
It was amazing.
It was humbling is what it was to see
all these dudes ahead of you that um,
their instant reaction,
you know,
it wasn't a little retrospective
perspective of like what you're doing in
your life.
It was like,
fuck this.
Those dudes just flew planes into our
buildings.
I'm going,
you know,
that's,
that's what they were where I was a
little bit late.
So I think just the response is
humbling.
Yeah,
it's very tricky because the people that
flew the planes are already dead,
right?
So,
but the,
the idea that there is a faction of the
world that's planning things along these
lines and it's willing to go to such
extreme lengths when you,
when you see shit like that happen in
the world and you see it from a
perspective of an outsider versus seeing
it from a perspective of someone who's
actually there and in the military,
what,
what is the difference?
What is the feeling like?
Like it's once you became active duty,
once you're there,
what is the difference in your
perspective?
Uh,
you know,
nine slash 11.
I think everybody remembers exactly
where they were.
You know,
I'm no different.
I remember the exact place that I was
and exactly what I was doing.
Um,
you know,
and I remember my response being anger,
like I wanted to lash out and revenge.
I don't have that,
that's not in me anymore.
Like I don't,
I never respond that way anymore.
When I see things happen.
I almost had like this cold calculated
response,
you know,
like,
um,
you know,
I hear about something happening and I
don't want to go over with a baseball
bat and smashed a bunch of dudes heads
in like I did,
you know,
12 years ago now.
It's like when bin Laden was killed,
you know,
I spent some prime years of my life and
mountains of Afghanistan,
Pakistan looking for that,
that idiot.
And um,
and then navy seals go in and get them,
you know,
and I was like,
Dang,
I missed it.
You know,
I was kind of sad.
I wasn't mad.
I wasn't angry.
I didn't want to be there.
I don't want to shoot it myself.
But I was like,
Oh man,
you didn't want to shoot them yourself.
I'm not,
I would love to have shot him myself,
but I wasn't mad that I didn't get to,
which was my response,
you know,
11,
12 years ago just calculated like,
ah,
man,
that whole event was one of the biggest,
like what do you think really happened?
Conspiracies online when they didn't
show the body and they threw it in the
ocean.
And the whole idea that he was going to
be a martyr like that was so perplexing
to me.
The whole thing was so completely
perplexing to me.
Like why wouldn't you just show his body
like,
can we,
can we take a look?
The whole world wants to see the bad guy
when you,
when you just historically through the
course of this war,
when we've done it on numerous
instances,
whether it's Saddam hanging or Zarqawi
and it's blown up body.
Like some.
I was involved with someone I wasn't.
It's been,
it's been very clear the response by the
fanatic side when they see the body,
you know,
maybe that person becomes a martyr,
and then then he's like idolized for
years or maybe it just incites and
immediate riot.
So yeah,
it sucks.
We want to have that justice feeling of
like the conclusion that,
you know,
like the finale of like,
ah,
there's been lot and he's dead.
Look at that point.
The beard of his.
That's definitely him.
Alright,
we can sleep at night.
You know,
the Boogeyman bin Ladin it's not under
the bed.
But had they done that,
the repercussions would have been so
much more severe with riots and
possibly,
you know,
a longstanding martyrdom.
So I don't know.
Yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Shades of gray,
like you said,
it sucks.
Yeah,
I'm selfish.
Yeah.
I want to see the dead body.
And plus I don't totally believe
everything they say.
So you know,
when you,
when you talked to high ranking,
military guys would say,
that guy's been dead forever.
He's been dead a long time ago.
That was another part of the conspiracy
guys that were in the know is saying,
I think that guy was dead already.
There's no way that he's still alive
because we've probably killed him like
10 times now.
So whether this was the final version of
him or the 10th,
it's irrelevant.
All versions have been loud and her
dead.
Yeah.
He's not Jason.
I'm going to pop up out of the ocean the
11th time.
Swim to shore.
A to bitch.
Yeah.
Let's start from scratch.
The idea is a terrifying to us,
like fanatical religious fundamentalists
that are willing to die is terrifying
for a good reason.
It's one of the worst aspects of human
beings is that we can talk people and to
believe in some completely ridiculous
shit and talk them into believing it so
much so that they're willing to kill
themselves and we all.
The other problem with human beings is
that once a guy gets that far,
once it got once a human man,
woman,
whatever it was that far gone,
how do you bring it back?
I don't.
I have a friend who has adopted a child
and I'm.
The kid was a,
I think she was probably three when they
adopted her and she's six now and the
poor kid's a mess,
you know?
And they really worried.
They don't know what she experienced a
lot of abuse before they ever got to her
and now she's six years old and they're
just trying to wrangle her and educator
and give her love and give her.
But they were like,
God damn,
if we just got there sooner,
that's the idea.
You're talking about three years old,
you know,
get some guy who's fucking 30 and he's
all.
I walk by all day,
you know,
bowing and ready to be a martyr,
and it's fucking.
It's impossible to change the course of
that sort of ideology.
Yeah.
I have no idea how,
if you're smart,
ecstasy,
mushrooms,
isolation,
reprogramming some of the solution was
way easier.
I'm definitely more repercussions.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
We're all going to live.
We're all going to die.
And you gotta pull weeds out of a
garden.
Sometimes.
That's just the reality
of the situation.
The idea of equating a human being like
a weed.
It's pretty gross,
but it's just a bad analogy.
We're not all flowers.
Yeah.
I don't think you're a flower a.
no,
I don't think I'm a flower.
I'm a vegetable.
Some sort of.
I'm already choke.
I have.
Layers are great.
I love artichokes.
I'm like a pineapple.
I'm rough on the outside,
but inside I'm delicious,
but the core is really hard as well.
So.
Yeah.
Well,
and it's you deep inside.
I'm very fibrous.
Once he gets good metaphor.
I like it.
Um,
so you were over there and uh,
you continued your mixed martial arts
training while you were over there as
well.
Yeah.
Special Forces as a whole.
Like there's the expectation that all of
us are just good fighters.
Like we're just born bad asses that
obviously this is not the case,
right?
Nobody is.
So we train,
you know,
we shoot all day long and morning and
night.
We fight know,
usually pet is some form of Jujitsu,
boxing,
wrestling,
kickboxing,
hand to hand combat,
small arms and then evening is more
recreational.
You know,
after you get back from the rain show,
you get up,
you work out,
then you go to the range and shoot for,
you know,
three,
four hours,
go back,
clean the guns,
and then your evening is usually on the
mat.
That's Monday through Thursday.
Friday is you're trying to fix whatever
you broke during the week.
That's the week.
So do you guys,
when,
when they set up training for you,
whether it's physical martial arts
training or fitness training,
as is their instructors who are,
who set a program for you?
Like how does,
how does it work?
So sometimes you bring in experts,
you know,
hoists Gracie came in,
trained us,
I can't,
countless times,
you know,
Greg Jackson comes out still,
um,
you know,
guys like,
uh,
I'm Greg Thompson,
you know,
he's a hoist black belt.
He's there permanently.
So there there's permanent fixtures at
the special forces installations that
train guys on a daily basis and they
have relationships to bring in experts.
Um,
obviously you know,
what you do in a house when to blow a
door in,
when you're going inside on kill.
Capture mission is different than you're
going to do in the cage.
So it has to be guys that can adapt
whatever they're teaching or know what
their limitations are.
You know,
Greg Jackson doesn't go in there and,
and try to teach knife fighting,
you know,
he knows what his left and right limits
are,
but he comes,
you know,
he's one of the best.
So he comes in and gives,
gives the best instruction that he can
to try to provide tools for,
for guys to be better at what they do.
You train a lot down there in
Albuquerque?
I do,
yeah.
He's a fascinating guy.
He is,
he is a cool cat.
He's a one of a very unique dude,
like really humble,
like really humble.
Like there's a lot of people that
pretend to be humble,
but if you took away Adam,
you pick away at them and you find some
bullshit.
It's just putting on a.
Now he's humble to a fault to a fault.
Yeah.
How so?
Um,
he and Winkeljohn I say humble to a
fault where they have a,
they have all these things to give.
They're the best that there has ever
been on coaching staff.
The train more champions.
They have the best stable of fighters on
the planet arguably.
And they're still training guys,
you know,
and it's not been designed and this is
just out of like a almost necessity at
this scary staff now.
It's not even scared.
I don't know.
I'm out of a Bar,
barn warehouse,
industrial,
commercial,
ghetto building,
you know,
like where I can walk out the door and
score some meth as fast as I can come
inside and get around with John Jones,
you know,
those are my options.
Front door parking lot.
Get some meth.
Come in.
It's that bad.
A neighborhood.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
You ever see is the outside?
No,
no.
Jackson winkeljohn driving down central.
It's like you can count anywhere from
four to eight transvestites any given
morning and then variety of.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a famous one named grace.
She's this beautiful black girl that
wears this huge wig and she's like four
or five inches taller than I am and
probably 50 pounds bigger than I am.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And,
but it's,
you know,
he bring her in.
I know she's amazing.
Scary guy can bring her in and every
corner is like,
oh,
there's that drug dealer,
there's this drug dealer.
And then you're like,
wait,
is that the guy from breaking bad?
No.
Maybe it is.
Is He really selling meth?
And then the irony is there.
No,
that is not the guy from breaking bad,
but he's really selling meth and he's
dressed like the guy from breaking bad.
Wow.
Yeah.
That is what it's like.
They're albuquerque is a weird spot.
It is cookie.
Why do they stay?
It's just because the gyms there and
yeah.
Good.
Stable of tough guys there.
I mean I would love it if Mike
Winkeljohn,
Greg Jackson,
you know,
let's say we're in Austin,
Texas or la or San Louis Obispo,
but they're in Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
so that's where I go.
If they're in Idaho,
that's where I would go,
but that's where they are.
So you're trained in Austin during your
time in between fights?
Yes.
How do you,
uh,
how do you like plan out?
Like,
like when,
like how many weeks do you give yourself
when you go to albuquerque?
I get six weeks.
Six good weeks and Albuquerque,
um,
so,
you know,
hopefully you'll get 10 week heads up,
heads up to your fight.
So then I have four weeks to start doing
pre fight camp,
develop like strength,
speed,
explosion type physical stuff,
working on specific techniques and then
moved to albuquerque for the six weeks
for the kind of final fight.
Can you train it?
A great spot in Austin too.
I was down there.
I'm really recently and I met the owner
of that facility with what's that got
stolen?
Parks and polio.
Brandao yeah.
Great facility.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Really Nice guys too.
Yep.
And um,
so you do just all your most inbetween
fight preparation.
They're good group of fighters out there
as well.
Yeah.
Side Austin elite.
Justin Lake was my strength and
conditioning coach.
He's like my brother on a whole bunch of
different levels.
He married my sister or my,
um,
my wife's sister,
where you used to go to college
together.
We used to hang out with the same girls
together and then we enlisted together.
He went to special forces.
We went to some group together,
went to Afghanistan together and then he
married my sister in law.
He might be stocking,
you know,
I hope not because he's like 200 pounds.
The snatches 250 pounds dead lift,
500 pounds.
It would be a bad thing if he was
stalking me.
Does.
Is he finding his.
He do,
man.
No,
just trains.
Just trains.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those dudes that are
scary that just trying to please,
please don't ever get mad at me,
tear my limbs off and beat me.
How did you get hooked up with a Jackson
Winkeljohn?
When I,
when I lost the strikeforce title to
Jacques Rey,
um,
it was,
it was a really close fight,
very close fight.
I thought you won.
I thought I did too,
but it was close and there was just
small adjustments I needed to make and
adjustments that w that I wasn't making
on my own.
I needed somebody that was smarter than
me to tell me what those were and how
to,
and how to prepare for them.
Um,
you know,
so since then,
um,
what seven and one since I went there,
you Jackson is an interesting guy in
that he didn't have any professional mma
fights,
but he's a virtuoso.
I mean he really is like,
I've had long conversations with him
about strategy and weird shit about
music,
about how,
you know,
he listens to symphonies and compares
the rhythm of symphonies to the,
the,
the changing rhythm of a fight.
He looks at everything as strategy,
whether it's like he's playing lemmings,
like the old school lemmings,
you know,
or is that,
I don't even know what that is.
Oh,
it's a video game where you like move
lemmings to certain portions of the map
to try to achieve some stupid
engineering goal.
Um,
it's very like archaic,
like 16 bit game from like almost
commodore 64 type things.
Right?
Like he still plays stat.
Not often,
but he's like,
you know,
everything has strategy,
whether it's chess or backgammon,
you know,
or if he's like playing monopoly with a
family,
you know,
it's like everything's about strategy.
Nope.
We had a conversation with my friend
Ari,
my friend Ari Shaffir has a podcast
called the skeptic tank and our,
he's a really smart dude and him and
Greg Jackson.
Greg was his guest and Greg was like
picking his brain about the comparisons,
like trying to figure out how one crafts
a piece of comedy and like tries to
attack an audience with it.
Like how you,
how you get an idea past the boundaries
of someone's consciousness.
Could that be adaptive?
Yeah.
When you're talking to this audience,
you already have the template of what
you're trying to get to them,
but then your response,
their responsiveness,
can you,
can it change?
Like I envisioned that is exactly
something that Greg would do.
Yeah.
It's fascinating to listen to,
to his,
his mind because
I don't know anybody like him.
It's a very unique sort of a mindset.
And then Winkeljohn who's a great
striking coach was a great kick boxer
himself.
You know,
he's an interesting guy too.
Yeah.
He's like the Yin to the Yang with Greg,
you know,
he's,
he's a linear thinker,
you know,
he's um,
he knows what you like,
what Greg wants you to paint the best
version of yourself.
I'm winkle.
John doesn't have that kind of
responsive approach to you.
He knows what you need to do to be
better,
you know,
and he says,
this is what you should do to be better.
And this is what we're going to drill it
relentlessly until your,
you know,
Greg's like,
all right,
like I want to see you develop this.
Let me give you some tools so you can
implement this in your fighting style.
And it's going to be adaptive to every
single different athletes that he has
where winkle.
John's like,
no,
this is what you need to do.
And this is how we're going to do it.
You're like,
yes sir,
please don't hurt me.
You know what I do?
I look at what do I look at for folks
who don't know,
he lost an eye in training.
Uh,
someone,
uh,
they threw a kick and the toenail missed
the pad and caught his eyeball,
which is the first I've ever heard of
that happening.
However,
I've heard of guys getting scratched
badly and training from sparring,
but never from holding pads.
He wears safety glasses every time he
holds.
Now we asked him,
can you see anything out of that other?
No,
definitely not.
No.
That the,
the.
I like poured out of his face.
He was like,
that's.
That was my,
I fuck.
Safety tracks your toenails bitches.
Seriously?
Do I get on the mat fingernails and
toenails and hygiene.
Like,
no,
I'm not rolling with you.
Go clean herself and trim that stuff.
Yeah.
I got one of the nastiest infections
once from a guy peeling my hooks off and
he had just giant fingernails.
Like I brought it out to the class.
I'm like,
come here folks,
look at this.
You can have,
this is you're going to fuck everybody.
It's not going to make you better
fighter.
We can't have this toenail clippers in
my Jujitsu bag,
belt headgear,
mouthpiece,
toenail clippers,
and file them bitches to cut them.
And then there's rough edges.
File those bitches down.
Yeah.
When you see guys like about to go into
the cage,
and herb dean would look at their nails
and then they're like,
they bite.
I'm like,
no,
this is not the time for that.
You don't bite them down.
Now you should have done that already.
Then you come home and your wife's like,
why do you have scratches all over you?
You're like,
I fight for a living.
That's hilarious.
Why are they on your back?
Because someone who's fucking scratching
my back.
I didn't want them to the moon.
Scratches o Tim.
Oh,
more.
More?
Yeah.
Not Good.
Um,
is there a solution for fucking it pokes
gloves?
What?
What should be done?
Heaven forbid we ever say that anything
was done better and pride.
Their gloves are,
they're better,
right?
They're better.
They're curved.
Got like how many guys right now do you
see with broken hands?
A lot.
It's like tons of them.
So we have this padding on the two
thirds of our hands.
Right?
Well that's not where we break our
hands.
We break her hands in the metacarpals in
the back of the wrist or just above the
wrist of the bottom.
Your hand pride gloves had padding there
which provided support.
So it's a lot harder to break your
hands.
There are also,
the pattern was curved so it was
actually actually had to straighten
your.
I'm a grappler obviously,
you know,
like I like to grapple.
So as a grappler I could complain that
like I want to have the total use of my
extremities.
Right?
No gloves would be better for most
grappler.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You could slide things in better you.
I said I don't want to get poked in the
eye.
So the pride gloves,
that's how we make them better.
Yeah.
Why we own pride the UFC owns and just
take the word slide off of it and then
put those three letters on there.
Bam.
Yeah.
They brought some new glove and they're
like,
here's the new glove,
and I put it on.
It was like,
why?
What the fuck is the difference?
It's just slightly curved,
like these bitches should be like really
curved,
like whereas if you want to do that,
it said an effort and when you relax it
goes right back to that.
The effort is for 15 to 25 minutes.
Like I'm sure my hand is strong enough
to go like that when I need it to for 15
to 25 minutes.
Well I mean as long as you can do it
when certain situations like,
you know,
you try and apply a choke or something,
but it's very disheartening to me.
All the people that are having detached
retinas and Alan Belcher's was fucked up
my.
I mean bisping bisping Xyz off looked at
him in the eye when we were like,
well he's an oil in the oil and is high.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't know what he can see out of it
or what it looks like.
I mean,
I guess it's diminished in some respect.
Has to be.
Yeah.
It's so fucking weird and he's had a
couple of surgeries,
right?
Bisping's had more than one ice surgery.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
I don't want them there.
I need them.
Is it possible to do something where the
fingers aren't exposed,
like chop them off?
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about like covering like
what I was thinking of is like a,
like a lamb skin sort of uncovering
something is not thick,
but like maybe like a band around the
tips where you,
you don't really do this ever anyway.
Know do you?
When do you do that body lock takedown
of stuff?
You grabbed like this?
No,
no,
but you do this.
You still have this or this.
I don't know.
I mean,
do you mostly do this?
Let's design it.
Okay,
well I'm saying what I'm for folks who
are listening,
there's a thing called the gable grip
and with the way a gable grip works is
picture your hand.
If you're going to karate chop someone
in your fingers.
Your thumb was pressed tightly against
society or hand.
Then have your hands like in across
position where one,
one sideways and one is a sitting
straight up and then crushed down with
your hands,
with your,
with your fingertips.
That would be what a gable grip is like
and that is the majority of wrestling of
grabbing.
When you you sent around the
waist,
that's most of the way you grabbed the
other way would be an escrip,
which is you would make like an like 69,
69.
That's it.
Ian and Yang.
If you're more uncouth or couth and you,
you grabbed like that,
but you never very rarely do you do
this.
Very rarely do you let your fingers
intersect with each other.
So it just doesn't.
They don't have to be free like that.
And when they're free,
that's when fingers go and eyeballs.
You know,
I thought maybe like maybe there could
be some sort of a flexible rounded
covering which would eliminate.
Seems like they've had to have tried it,
you know?
I don't think they have.
Let's give it a whirl.
It's,
it's amazing to me how things just stay
stagnant when they're retarded.
Like when they don't,
they don't make any sense like these
gloves.
So 12 to six elbow.
I love those.
Why can't we do those?
This should be at ease to the ground.
Yeah.
Well you telling me you can kick someone
in the head with your Shin,
but you can't drop an elbow down your
head.
Someone has never been kicked in the
head with a shin.
Obviously.
That's the only reason why you would
make that really think John Mccain for
this one,
wasn't it?
That like that.
That era was that era according to John
Mccarthy who was there when it was all
going on.
John McCarthy,
famous referee,
the gold standard.
That guy,
great guy.
Big John told me that they were having
this meeting with the athletic
commission and they had seen like karate
brick breaking demonstrations on espn at
like 2:00
in the morning and the board's shatter
and everything.
Well they said you can't do that move
because that move could kill someone.
Yeah.
If you can break bricks,
you can obviously break somebody's neck.
Exactly.
And just blow.
This is the real reason why the 12 to
six elbow is illegal,
but arguably this elbow is stronger.
Definitely.
It's got more,
more torque to it.
It's a more natural movement of the
body.
This is an awkward movement in
comparison.
Yeah,
but I mean the Cobra Kai,
Daniel's son watched those guys breaking
boards.
Yeah.
It's tough to argue with that kind of
logic.
That is the logic that literally is
complete pure ignorance.
If you.
If you asked like mixed martial arts,
a competitor's trainers,
fighters,
people in the know and as them,
which would be illegal,
the 12 slash six elbow is not going to
be on that list.
No where near.
It's a fine.
It's a.
it's a good technique.
It's excellent as our knees on the
ground.
I think knees on the ground and it could
be,
you know,
if,
if someone wanted to have some sort of a
compromise,
maybe it would be knees on the ground
when you're not pressed up against the
cage.
That could be a possibility.
You know,
the idea being that the niece of the
head on the ground would be problematic
against the cage because the guy
couldn't move and that was one of the
good things about pride was the ropes.
If soccer kicks and all those things,
you can kind of scoot your head under
the ropes to get away from things you're
not,
you're not contained by your
environment.
And to the point where you would suffer
a damaging blow that you could have
avoided by your own power.
I mean,
outside of like
the north south 69 position for knees to
the head on the ground.
That's the only position I could think,
you know,
like obviously the limitation is you
still can't strike to the top of the
head or the back of the head with a knee
and that under that premise then it
doesn't really matter.
Um,
we need somebody from.
Because you can't hurt them any worse
than you could in any other way with any
other strike from any other position.
So yeah,
and also I don't like this thing that
guys are doing with a drop one hand down
to avoid.
But they had and they picked it up,
drop it down like,
oh,
let's game.
Play this down,
down,
down.
Don't need me.
Yeah,
I'm up.
Well,
it's,
it's very,
very weird.
It's just a,
it's a weird gray area that I think
needs to be sat down.
And then of course there's the scoring
system which is adopted from boxing this
10 point scoring system,
which is just terrible.
And the implementation of it is even
more terrible because very few 10,
eight rounds get scored.
Yeah.
I mean I've rarely.
There's 10,
nine rounds that are squeakers,
right?
Like maybe one of your rounds with
Jacques,
right?
Might've been at 10,
nine round and then there's 10,
nine rounds where a guy just gets
fucking molly [inaudible] dropped to
three times 10,
nine round.
Like how is that possible?
It's a terrible system and I don't know
if you ever saw doc Hamilton's scoring
system.
He had a half point scoring system,
which is much more better.
Way Better.
I would want doc Hamilton's and to know
what the scores are every road.
I agree 100 percent.
I agree.
Every other fucking game,
whether it's football,
basketball,
everything else.
I think it should be that way in boxing
too.
So it would discourage shitty judges
from continuing their.
Their shittiness Yup.
And shitty fighters from continuing
their shittiness.
Yes.
You know,
the only real worry would be that guy
would be so far ahead that he would run
in the last round.
He's up for rounds.
John Jones move into fifth round against
glover was like,
alright,
I have this,
but a guy like John wouldn't do that
anyway.
Yeah.
The great fighters would still fight the
same and that not only that,
the other guy is going to get more
desperate so it'll make it even more
exciting because he's going to have to.
And if he doesn't like,
well,
will you not trying to win.
Like you know,
you're not going to win a decision,
so either you just fucking throw caution
to the wind and throw yourself in the
line of fire or why you fighting.
Move on.
Yeah.
John Jones is a fucking phenomenon,
man.
That dude is good.
As he has looked in the past,
the fight against glover was just,
just sensation was masterful.
It was like,
it was something to behold.
I was like,
he's amazing to the gym.
He's,
I mean,
he's so talented in every respect,
you know,
like even I've been doing Jujitsu for
forever and he's good.
He's really,
really good.
And then like stand up as a whole
different world.
His wrestling is just out of this world,
like,
and then he goes on game day on fight
day and he's better.
He improvises today.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
When,
when I asked him about the elbows in
tight,
like fighting glover against the cage
like that,
I knew I just had a fucking feeling that
he was improvising,
that I was like,
is this something you planned as like,
no,
I just felt it.
He was winding up and I just felt like I
could get away with that.
Uh,
we're in fight camp are the exact same
time I fought one week before him and
uh,
he did drill those,
you know,
like we're watching out for glover's big
overhand.
Right.
You know,
obviously we're looking for the two big,
the two,
three punch combos that he doesn't,
entrances,
you know,
watching of course for her,
for glover's wrestling,
he's a beast on top.
Um,
and then you watched the fight and
you're like,
he didn't do that stuff in fight camp.
He just fight night,
started improvising and destroying the
still number two dude on the planet.
So decisive leader.
It's disturbing.
He also added in
new thing to his game that I think
you're gonna.
See a lot of people do.
That's,
that attacking the shoulder with that
loose underhook.
When a guy has that relax under hook and
you yank that arm up,
me,
he fucked glover shoulder up in the
first one
round.
Never really recovered.
Oh,
it changed the whole feeling of what
glover could do offensively from that
point forward.
Yeah.
He,
he was mangled and now you know,
his Labor was towards the surgery and
surgery.
Yeah.
John's done a lot of things that a lot
of people implement now.
The front leg side kick to the thigh and
it was very few people doing that before
him.
Everybody does it.
He's got to watch the finger pokes
though,
man.
John has always doing that thing where
it's extending his hands and you guys
trying to move forward.
They wind up running into his fingers
all the time.
Yeah,
I really do believe I hate finger pokes
knee to the groin when guys get tired,
cage grabbing like don't like it at all.
So He's a teammate.
Um,
I really do believe that he doesn't
intend to hit them in the eyes.
He likes controlling range and he has an
open hand out,
you know,
to try to set that range and to,
and responsively counter attack and just
like you said,
guys just run into it,
you know,
he's not trying to poke him,
but it's his fault because his hands
open and his fingers are freaking
pointing up there.
Yeah.
I don't think he's doing an
intentionally either,
but it is an issue.
Has to change.
It happened with Gustafson and half,
one glover,
you know,
it's um,
it's a very,
it's a very tricky situation because on
one hand it's a good tactic.
It's a good tactic to try to palm the
forehead and you know,
I mean,
it's a big one in Moitai,
but tie,
of course you're dealing with a fully
enclosed glove.
I don't know what the fuck they can do,
what they really need to do something
and it needs to be a priority.
Gloves,
Prague,
gloves.
There it is,
man,
when you watch pride.
And I've been watching a lot of pride
lately because I,
um,
at home,
uh,
I,
yeah,
it's fucking awesome.
Greatest Shit ever.
You know,
it's really interesting to watch the
evolution of the sport too.
When you watch pride,
you watched like guys and you compare
them to the best guys of today and like,
wow,
this is like a,
there's been a big fucking jumped,
big fucking jump.
I love Don Frye and his mustache.
Rest in peace,
mustache.
But you look,
that's crazy.
But like Don fry in pride compared to
the light heavyweights,
now I'm just the disparity of,
of skill and technical level.
Even athleticism and don was a beast.
Um,
it's night and day.
Well,
I was watching vandelay the best of
vandelay in pride.
There was an episode in the best of
pride where it was all vandalized fights
and you know,
vandelays one of my favorite fighters to
watch.
It's a wild man,
but you know,
you compare his skill level to like a
guy like Jon Jones who they're fighting
at the same weight class.
Like that wouldn't even be a hard fight
for like a round.
Yeah.
It would not be a,
it would be you can't touch me and I'm
going to keep hitting you and you're
going to not know what to do and then
either you're going to get choked,
unconscious or,
or beat the fuck up.
Yeah.
It's amazing how much of a jump.
There's bins from 93 to 2014 as far as
the evolution of martial arts.
And I say it like it's a line that I
keep saying,
but it's true in those two decades,
martial arts have evolved more than they
have in the last 2000 years.
It's incredible.
Absolutely.
To longest time,
man.
You know,
I grew up doing martial arts in the
eighties and nobody knew what the fuck
worked.
It was all just guessing.
You know,
everybody knew that,
you know,
if you were a really good wrestler,
you could take guys down and if you are
really good box so you could probably
punch better,
but what would work better?
Karate or judo,
what will work better?
Jiu Jitsu it nobody knew.
Nobody fucking knew.
It was a guessing game.
Naming new moves.
Every single card.
You're like,
oh,
what are you gonna?
Call this one.
Like how can we progress so quickly
where every Saturday night we're like,
oh,
here's a new submission.
You know?
It's just unbelievable.
Yeah.
The Peruvian Necktie,
Tony D'souza,
which you very rarely see.
I mean CB dollar is probably the only I
think.
I don't even know if the Sousas ever
pulled it off inside the octagon,
but cb Dahl always pulled it off,
is a few guys that use that Peruvian
neck time and then there's a.
there's,
there's a few jokes that you,
you know,
you see them once and then you never see
them again.
It's,
it's a fascinating thing where you're
watching all this stuff evolve.
Right?
Right.
In front of your eyes.
How do you manage your training when it
comes to like working on new techniques,
adding new things to your arsenal and
instill just the conditioning,
the sparring,
the day to day drilling that you have to
do.
Like how do you manage stuffing,
all that stuff in
time management.
Like a good athlete,
you know,
I do things like ratios,
percentages of k I want to develop or
give a certain percentage of time to
getting better.
So I'm going to,
let's say I have 10 classes a week.
I'm just real easy round number in that
in those 10 classes,
you know like I want two or three of
them to be exclusively focused on
drilling new techniques,
you know,
that I want two or three of them to be
maintenance of things that I do well and
want to continue to do well.
And there's just,
just grappling like in,
in a,
in a one week,
10 class setting and then you know,
two or three of them are,
are hard grappling,
sparring type sessions,
you know.
Then the other ones like maybe a float
or of I'm teaching or I'm working with
just a handful of black belts trying to
create new stuff,
you know,
so like it's equally proportionate to
stain.
Good.
Challenging myself physically and
developing new technique and learning.
You know.
What about recovery?
Like what about um,
what,
what do you do stuff for the birds?
What do you do for fun?
Do you have like a routine as far as
like deep tissue massage,
Cryo therapy?
What do you do?
Yes.
To both of those.
So Austin,
cryotherapy.
I'm there because I'm one of those
things.
You stand in one of those chambers and
it's 50 below zero.
Negative 300 is that happens your Dick.
When you do that,
that seems to me it'd be gloved fingers.
Right?
And I take those gloved fingers and I
cover what is going to be my very small
penis in like seconds,
you know,
and I make sure I like double handed.
So both my hands are like,
yeah.
Does anybody go raw dog and just let
their Dick Freeze?
That would be a.
because if you found out that guy did
it,
you'd probably have to do it too.
Wouldn't you know,
I would assume that you would be one of
those guys.
I'd be like,
all right,
I am that.
I'm like,
I'm so stupid.
I'm going to do.
Really?
Are you messing with me?
I'm going to do it.
Yeah,
just do it.
A monk position.
Three minutes,
right?
Um,
and then you get out huge infusion of
blood.
You feel better.
What's the pro?
Eddie Bravo did this,
uh,
in preparation for his heuler match,
which is the first time I'd heard about
it.
Like explain it to me and for the lay
people at home,
it's your neck is above your head of
exposed.
Yeah.
So the closes on you suntanning
bed.
Exactly.
But you're,
you're standing up,
right?
They punched,
punched liquid nitrogen gas in there.
So up I about your chin down to like
negative 300 degrees.
So you're breathing,
the gas is coming up to your Chin and
um,
you know,
the largest organ in your body is your
skin.
So it's very responsive.
It can absorb quickly and people take
drugs that way.
Uh,
you know,
you can also,
it's very responsive,
so it gets exposed to negative 300
degrees.
The first thing it does is take blood
from the extremities and rushes it to
the vital life sustaining organs of your
body,
your brain,
your heart,
and your lungs.
So all the blood goes from your
extremities to your core and then you
get in.
You're there for like two,
three minutes and super crazy because if
you have an injury like a hurt knee or a
hurt hand where you have extra fluid
there,
it gets super cold there because you
have more fluid there and more fluid is
conductive and it gets colder faster.
So you can feel these injuries on your
body.
Get crazy cold and then you hop out.
Three minutes is up,
you get out of the get out of the
chamber and then your body responds to
being an 80 degrees and all the Rut,
all the blood rushes back out to the
extremities.
So you get this huge infusion of good
healthy blood back out to these injuries
and out to your extremities.
It's a rush.
Feels like you just drank five cups of
coffee and you're like Hampton,
uh,
it's just this weird tingley fantastic,
um,
sensation.
So that's what happens.
And how does it help you recover by
doing the infusion circulation like the,
in the trying to treat an injury,
you know,
you have,
you have rest,
ice,
compression,
elevation,
you know,
when,
when you're trying to work on recovery
without injury,
you want circulation so you want good
healthy blood going to muscles that
you've just fatigued to increase
recovery and response time.
So if you just like simple terms,
if I went and did like a big squat and
deadlift workout for the day,
right?
My legs and back and are going to be
sore,
you know those extremities,
law,
it's vascular region.
So go hop in the cryo chamber.
All the blood that's sitting there in
that area,
in my legs,
my back and my butt.
I'm all rushed to my brain and lungs and
heart.
Then I get out and all sorts of great
new,
fantastic blood goes back to my legs,
back and.
But so I get a great,
huge infusion of good healthy blood back
out to my extremities to increase
recovery time because I'm just
increasing circulation.
Increasing circulation is increasing
recovery.
Wow.
That's fascinating shit man.
It's,
it's fascinating when you see all these
new innovations when it comes to
strength and conditioning and recovery
and fitness.
And that's a,
that's a unique one,
man.
That's,
that's interesting stuff.
It's cold though.
Yeah.
How many days a week do you do that for?
And they have a place like that in
Albuquerque.
No,
they don't.
They have a trailer that sometimes
they'll,
they'll bring out to me and in fight
camps.
That
is,
that has that in it.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's nice.
That's super nice.
Wow.
So Albuquerque doesn't have that open.
Greg Jackson get on the ball,
but come on.
Should have that task.
Yeah,
deep tissues.
Great.
Um,
you know,
I,
I believe like the tenants,
the foundations of Bni,
healthy recovering athlete,
you know,
like good sleep,
good food,
good sex,
you know,
like you have to have those.
And if you're doing those things,
then your body's gonna adapt to whatever
the workload of volume that you're
putting out.
So I have a crazy volume like guys that
come and train with me.
They're like,
this is normal,
this is what I do normally buy.
Just have a very healthy foundation of a
lifestyle,
you know,
like we're,
I don't really drink,
I don't ever smoke,
you know,
like I train every single day to three
times a day.
Like this is my body's adaptive to that.
And then everything else,
the supporting structure of eating well,
you know,
having an awesome supplements.
Um,
you know,
having everything just to make my body
respond properly to training volume is,
is there.
So how do you work your diet out?
What do you,
uh,
do you do have a nutritionist that you
work with,
you do it on your own,
of all of the above,
you know,
like,
um,
I have nutritionists that I bounce stuff
off of and like people that are way
smarter than me that,
um,
and then I'm surrounded with so many
other elite athletes talking to them and
their coaches,
you know,
the guys on it,
they have a whole,
they have a stable of guys there that
are always looking for the next best
thing or even not the next best thing.
Things there just have been there around
for thousands of years that nobody uses
like they should.
So it's,
it's a constant discussion of like how
to improve.
I know what my calories that I'm burning
a day because I log everything.
Um,
you know,
I fought two weeks ago,
so I was on crazy strict diet for like
three,
four months to get down to one 85.
Now I'm back in Austin,
Texas.
Maybe I'll have a little bit of brisket.
It's getting in there.
You has some tacos.
So what,
which I think is actually needed.
You know,
you should,
you,
you can't be perfect all the time.
Your body needs those cheats.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think cheat days are important.
I think people that are just completely
clean and strict,
you're robbing yourself also of
enjoyment.
Yeah.
Life's too short and yeah,
there's some delicious food that you
shouldn't eat all the time,
but you should eat sometimes.
Definitely.
Right?
Yeah.
Um,
so do you,
when you say that you logged the amount
of calories that you burn,
how do you calculate that?
So heart rate monitor right during the
workout knows my resting metabolic rate
is key.
You have to know what that is and once
you know what that is kind of in between
workouts,
you know,
cumulatively in a day what you've burnt
and then you just add during the
workouts.
You know,
if I work out two or three times that
day,
you know,
if I'm doing a 90 minute strength and
conditioning session,
you know I'm going to burn anywhere
between 12 to 1600 calories in that
session.
You know,
from warm,
warm up to cool down.
And then like last night I had a two
hour Jujitsu Shush session,
you know,
like,
and it smashed afterwards,
you know,
like I know what my,
kind of,
what my heart rate was at during the
entire time and two hours,
you know,
that's going to be another 1500 calories
that I'm putting on top of what I
brought in that day.
So I guess snapshot that I bought,
you know,
5,500
to 6,000
calories.
That's insane.
Yeah.
That's way more than most people eat the
day.
Yeah.
It's fun to eat that though.
How do you stuff that in though?
I'm in the way.
What do you.
The Texas brisket.
So easy.
Do you have any other nutritional
requirements?
Like do you eat gluten?
Do you,
do you take sugar into your diet at all?
I try.
I try not to.
I'm definitely fight camp.
I don't have either of those,
you know,
but like right now,
um,
you know,
I had an apple fritter Bagel on Monday.
Like I hadn't had one of those and
I didn't even know how long and it was
amazing.
Is like a small orgasm in my mouth.
I don't even know what that is.
And the Apple Fritter Bagel?
No,
not Bagel.
Just an apple fritter.
Oh,
her donut.
okay.
So it's like just donut with apple,
gluten and sugar and apples.
Sugar and that sort of a.
What is that syrupy stuff in with the
apples and cinnamon has exactly what?
That sounds good.
It was good it yet.
Do Krispy Kreme it?
Do you ever Krispy Kreme it?
No.
You don't go to Krispy Kreme?
Damn dude know there's a spot that I go
to a I,
I'm again,
Regena keen.
Do you know what that is?
And something that they go to Germany
for that.
Uh,
Dr Peter Weller invented.
It's a blood spinning.
Oh yeah.
You guys are doing it too.
Yeah,
I've been getting it done.
I had it done on my neck.
I had a bulging disc in my neck that was
impinging on nerves.
I was getting some numbness in my hand
from Jujitsu.
Went away and totally the magic.
The thing just shrunk down to nothing.
But the place where I get it,
it's right down the street from Krispy
Kreme.
I drive,
I'm like,
do I want to fuck up what I just fixed,
just do it inflammation.
And um,
apparently inflammation.
And uh,
I found out about it from a physical
therapist that gluten and inflammation,
the,
they're like,
people say,
Oh,
you know,
you're not really gluten sensitive.
Most people aren't mean you can eat
gluten,
he be fine.
But the reality is it does cause some
inflammation more.
Eat the morning you get.
Yeah.
That's a fascinating thing that it's a
normal part of everybody's diet.
You wouldn't think that it would have
that sort of an effect on your joints or
your back or.
But it really does.
Yeah.
Well,
especially if they train,
like we do like that,
then now we're just compounding problems
where we have the enablers to cause
inflammation and then we're diet.
Giving something that helps cause it,
you know,
now things are just compounded and it's
exponential.
And then we actually like,
ah,
what about dairy?
Not much at all.
Some cheeses I just can't live without
your cheeses.
Your cheese guy mean.
Yes,
I'm a food guy.
If it's good,
I want it.
Yeah,
you cook,
right?
Oh God,
I love to cook.
What kind of,
what do,
what do you cook?
Um,
I love everything,
but I love cooking like real.
When I say real,
um,
it's my food that I shot.
It's that I cleaned that.
I froze that I packaged,
that I brought in from my greenhouse in
my backyard,
you know,
like my food.
Right,
right,
right.
So I,
I'm with you a thousand percent.
I love being connected to what I put in
my body.
Yeah.
There's very few people who have
experienced that haven't said that it's
something special when you cook an
animal that you actually hunted,
shot,
butchered,
cut up,
put in your freezer or eating in camp,
which is even better when you're eating
it like a couple of hours after it died.
This is an amazing connection that,
you know,
people will poopoo that,
like it's not important.
Like,
you know,
Oh,
you're just using that as an excuse to
go out and shoot animals.
Like,
no,
and I really wish those folks.
I would really like to take someone who
is his immediate or who's anting hunting
and just you need to just experience
this.
Just experienced 100 percent agree.
I wish every person that ate meat,
um,
and ironically a ton of anti hunters
like eat meat obviously.
Um,
there's no connection to food these
days.
People just want to go to the grocery
store and pick their stuff off the shelf
and have no idea how it got there,
what was put in there.
But then they judge me because I hunt.
But I know exactly where this animal
came from,
you know,
and like I felt sorry for it when I shot
it,
they thought it was beautiful
and I still do and I'm enjoying every
single bite of it,
but they.
But they're going to sit there and be
like,
aw man,
that guy hunts,
you know,
like I'm a,
I'm an absolute fanatic conservationist,
but I want.
Yeah.
And I love my food and I love good food.
So they're all connected and I think
people should wake up.
It's also what we were taught kind of
talking about earlier is that there's a.
there's a broad spectrum of things that
are going on in this world.
There is no black and white when it
comes to hunting.
You can actually love animals and still
shoot them and kill the level in that,
but it's a crazy thing like people have.
They find that like impossibly
contradictory,
but it's not and it's also the other
thing that people don't want to admit is
that if you do not shoot these animals,
they are going to continue to fuck.
They're going to continue to procreate
and then how are you going to control
the population because you have two
options.
Either you can hunt them or you can
bring in wolves.
So what do you want to do?
You want wolves wandering around through
your fucking neighborhood,
killing everything that they can get
ahold of,
including dogs,
including livestock.
Do you want wild panthers?
What do you want?
What do you.
How are you going to control the
populations of these animals that don't
have natural predators?
The first,
my experience,
I was like a prepubescent kid when
Catalina island off the coast of
California,
I'm somebody accidentally introduced a
hog to Catalina and it made it in boned
with maybe one or two other wild hogs
that were there that created this feral
big ass hog that made a whole bunch of
shit,
tons of more hogs and then started
destroying the entire island.
So they brought in hunters to x,
like get rid of these hogs that we're
destroying the,
the,
the entire ecosystem of the island.
Um,
and that happens on a much more.
That's the micro example on a tiny
little island with a tiny little animal.
But if you look at the big picture of,
you know,
like deer in the south or hogs from
Florida to Texas,
you know,
or the python that was introduced to the
everglades,
they have to be hunted to maintain the
balance of harmony in the ecosystem.
And the ecosystem will crash if it's not
done.
Uh,
so you either,
like you said,
give a Predator and the Predator has
serious problems that come along with
it.
Or You have the hunter that does it
properly and uh,
and then you have the benefits that come
along with it,
which is a proper ecosystem
and you get delicious wild Ham.
Look at that.
Yeah.
I smoked that bitch myself.
Okay.
That my backyard,
I shot it and I smoked it and it was the
best tasting ham ever.
Wild pig has a completely different
texture than anything.
It's,
it's like a,
we,
I marinated it or brined it rather for
seven days before I smoked it.
But even so it's like,
it's a more dense meet.
It's more muscle,
it's darker,
it tastes better.
It's better for you and
you fucking have to kill them because
there's 50,000
hogs.
The place where I go to is to hone
ranch.
We only an hour and a half outside of La
and they have elk.
They have a pond up there that they put
a trail camera on just to see what's
eating there.
16 different mountain minds.
Oh,
nothing.
Just 16 different fucking wild murderous
cats.
And it's because there's so many pigs,
there's so much.
There's so much game up there you could
in in from Texas to Florida,
you could bring in every hunter in the
nation and have them kill 10 pigs a
piece and it wouldn't even dent.
What's the population of wild hogs in
the southeast?
Have you ever seen a pork lips now?
No.
It sounds like the best movie ever.
It's a show.
There's this.
There's a dude.
His name is Brian,
I think is his name,
his name?
He's the guy from Texas and he's got a
show called pig man and a pig man is.
He's a hunter in Texas and he hunts wild
pigs and then he owns a barbecue place
and then serves up wild pig bbq.
Now he's got a show on one of those like
history or something like that.
It's called boss Hog and it shows sort
of details with doing.
I'm familiar with it.
Him and Ted nugent got helicopters with
fucking machine guns and they're flying
around with ars,
shooting pigs out of the sky.
I mean,
it is the craziest fucking thing I've
ever seen on TV.
That's legal now.
Yeah,
we pass through it.
Yeah.
You have to and,
but for folks that don't,
that's cruel,
that's horrible.
There are millions of pigs,
they don't care.
And they know not only that,
they don't stop fucking,
they breed all year round.
It's not like deer that have a Rut and
then they'll have a fond.
Now these are animals that are shitting
out four or five pigs every four or five
months and they just don't,
don't,
don't.
And this is a,
this is the video of them shooting these
things from the sky.
There's actually companies,
this is the wrong one.
You see what you're showing is there's a
pig hunting video that was a pig hunting
promo for the sportsmans channel,
but this is,
uh,
they,
they had a whole episode and in the
episode that killed 450 pigs in a
fucking 22 minute episodes with
commercials.
But that's like a drop in the ocean to
what's there.
Yeah.
Literally it is like taking a shot glass
and tossing the end to the ocean.
I mean,
it's the most ridiculous thing you've
ever seen in your life and they're just
catching these pigs running head shots
where they're tomblin while they're
running and there's something barbaric
and fucked up about it,
but they're taking that food and they're
feeding hungry people.
They have hunters for the hungry,
they give the wild pork,
which is excellent meat.
They give it to a hungry families and
it's really,
really,
really delicious food and it's important
to.
But then there's that thing where people
are like,
well,
that's fucked up,
man.
That's not really hunting.
They're shooting.
It's all,
they're not really hunting.
They're eradicating these problematic
delicious animals.
That's the best way to look at it.
They have to be eradicated.
And while it might not be the most
humane approach to it,
um,
it's an,
it's a necessary one that has to happen.
And so,
I dunno,
like it's a necessary evil a little bit.
Well,
you know,
what's going on in the Hamptons,
the Hamptons,
the luxury area outside of long island
where all these,
what's going on with rich folks,
they have so many deer up there that
they're bringing in snipers.
The snipers in the middle of the night
and the town is proposed to give these
deer birth control to somehow or another
give them food,
put food out that has birth control in
it,
which by the way,
the male deer are going to eat too,
so you can make bitches out of the male
deer.
The mail you're going to run around.
I think I'm fucking pregnant.
Why am I not true?
Yeah,
so you get to have these male deer.
They're eating birth control,
female deer,
and it's going to cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars and it's a direct
result of the failure to eradicate.
These animals are controller population
through hunting.
There's a place in Pennsylvania where
they have 24,
a 24 hour day,
seven day a week hunting,
365 days a year.
You can hunt with bows and arrows.
You can hunt all year around because
there are so many deer.
They're like just fucking bring in
hunters and the hunters come in and
there's these huge estates that have
these 10 acre properties where there's a
fucking tree stands and there's million
dollar houses with fucking putting green
courses and dudes and trees.
Dan's launching arrows at deer because
they're fucking everywhere.
They're like tree score,
like ground squirrels.
You ever driving a like a ranch that has
ground squirrels and as the car is
running you see like others run across
the road.
It's incredible.
Like to hone ranch which has 50,000
hogs.
It has rocky mountain elk,
gigantic elk.
They have thousands of deer.
They have bears,
they have mountains,
they have everything.
The number one animal mass,
pound for pound is ground squirrels,
and there's 2,700,000
acre ranch.
Number one is ground squirrels,
I believe it was my dad in.
Here's a narcotics officer for 30 years
door kicking superstar.
He spends his retired time now shooting
ground squirrels like the most amazing
setup.
Ground squirrels,
ground squirrels,
no it on the ranch.
Like the.
The cows will step in their whole break
their legs or they destroy irrigation
for the vineyards,
like they're nasty.
They're disease carrying and they also
breed like crazy.
You can't stop them.
They're cannibals too.
Like you shoot one to like drag it into
the hole and eat it.
Very different from tree squirrels.
Tree squirrels are actually good.
I've eaten tree squirrel.
They're delicious.
They're pretty.
They're tastes good man.
Steve Rinella.
The guy who was the host,
immediate or shadow squirrel when we
were in Wisconsin and cooked it and it
was real.
It's a very unique taste to it doesn't
taste like anything else.
But um,
ground squirrels,
man.
I eat one.
Yeah,
we currently can't.
Apparently.
They're just fucking disgusting.
Yeah.
It's like,
I mean,
I guess you could eat it if you were
starving to death,
but the other problem is if you shoot
them,
you have to kill them because if you
shoot them and you wound them,
they run into their hole and then the
other ones eat it.
Yeah.
Fucking creepy little nasty.
A lot.
A lot of creepy little animals out
there.
But this,
I mean the idea that there's one branch
with $2 million,
700,000
acres there,
largest largest animal mass is ground
squirrels.
Well,
they say that the largest mass of,
of life on earth moving life is aunts
and that there's more pounds of ants a
than there are humans,
pounds of humans.
It's incredible.
Yeah.
And they're like 10,000
times stronger than we are ratio.
Yeah.
They never get mad at us.
Or are they better not start growing.
You know,
if you go back throughout the history
and you find some of the animals that
were just really enormous just to a few
hundred million years ago and if somehow
or another shrunk down to a manageable
size.
Yeah.
Like if bees,
if bees of the size of horses,
we'd have real problems.
I love honey.
Yeah.
Honey is delicious.
You know,
vegans don't eat honey.
That's a horrible.
That's hilarious.
Just show if you ever want to know how
retarded it being a Vegan is,
you won't eat honey.
Uh,
either retarded.
The moment that they start with I'm a
Vegan,
you know.
Well they can't help say it.
It's like they're holding hands.
They run marathons.
Yeah.
Just like another thing that comes out
right away is like,
I'm a marathoner,
or I'm a Vegan,
or I eat Paleo,
or I'm a crossfit.
That's like nobody can help but tell you
those necessary elements of themselves.
Yeah.
What is that?
I don't know what it is.
It's they want to tell you they're
awesome,
but to me that almost discounts
discounts you as being such.
Yeah.
If you're a Vegan,
you cannot tell people for a long period
of time.
That's super impressive.
I'll like you more.
Wow.
You're a Vegan and you just.
It took you two weeks to tell me,
I'm impressed.
Can I buy you lunch of Vegan lunch?
I get it.
For people that don't want to be cruel,
I totally get the whole sentiment I get.
I get all of it.
I get the idea of like wanting to eat
fresh vegetables and it's healthy for
you.
I get it,
but the finite nature of life itself,
it's just.
It seems to me it's so silly that you
think that somehow under the EU not
killing animals is somehow going to
balance things out or you not being a
part of killing animals is going to bow.
They're killing each other.
Do you know that?
Like there's a war going on.
All the animals are involved in it,
including humans.
We're just so far ahead.
We forgot it's a war and we have POW
camps,
so we set up in cities,
we call them zoos and that's it.
That is that they didn't ask to be
there.
We capture those motherfuckers and we
put them and they're in these weird
things where we don't let them interact
with the other animals in the zoo.
We,
we blocked them off in their own little
apartments and you know,
so we could stare at him all we popcorn.
I'm not sure I agree with that.
I don't.
I think that if you should have zoos,
you should lump all those bitches
together and if you run out of monkeys,
go get more.
The monkeys,
the monkeys that survive are going to be
the ones that know how to get away from
the cat.
He's a bad ass.
That monkey.
I want us to pet.
Yeah,
that's a monkey.
Knows that to zig and zag.
He knows that a Juke,
you know when the cat's coming,
he knows that to gets to the type.
The tall branches,
the monkey that stays in the ground and
picks his ass while the Jaguars slowly
creeping up on him.
That's the monkey that's supposed to
die.
The only weird part about the shoe
worlds and the zoos have this of,
of our life is that they do.
I love when people are like,
oh,
did you see the movie black fish?
You know,
like,
it's so horrible.
I'm going to boycott seaworld.
You're like,
have you ever given a cent to marine
biology or the preservation of marine
wildlife?
No,
but you're going to boycott seaworld.
How much money have they given in the
research and preservation of marine
wildlife?
Oh yeah.
A thousand times more than you.
It's the same with the zoos.
You know,
like,
I don't like zoos.
I think it's horrible that the animals
were there,
but they do more in research and
understanding wildlife and the
preservation of wildlife.
Then almost everyone that goes there and
then or doesn't go there and complained
about it,
so it's just like this.
Again,
shades of gray.
My problem with seaworld is very simple.
Those animals are smart.
They're very smart.
In fact,
the cerebral cortex of a dolphin's 40
percent larger than that of a human
being so beautiful.
We don't even understand how smart they
are because they can't alter their
environment,
so we don't think of them as being smart
because they can.
They don't have funds.
They don't pick things up because they
can move in three d all around the
ocean.
They can fucking dive and swim and move
around and they have these pods.
They stay together,
they have families,
they have dialects,
they have languages.
There are so intelligent that we,
we,
we're just now starting to understand
that they have variations in the way
they speak depending upon what
geographic location they're at.
They're really fucking smart human type
smart and just because they're different
from us and they don't build houses
doesn't mean they're not smart.
So to me it's like slavery.
It's like just because you know,
we have donated so much money into
slavery research,
but you're still fucking slave owners.
Yukon's,
you know,
the reason why there needs to be slavery
research.
I just think that anything smart
shouldn't be in captivity,
but like giraffes,
they're so stupid.
You go to the zoo and they seem happy as
fuck there is happy there and they let
babies feed them.
I have a three year old,
then she holds up lettuce.
The draft comes and take it.
That fucking drafts.
Not upset at all.
They're so confident that giraffes are
chill,
that they let babies freedom,
you know,
are there.
They are so chill.
They're just happy.
There's no lions for you to be a giraffe
all day.
You have a giant target.
Your neck is just a huge target or
beacon.
Somebody wants to bite.
There's not one spot.
It's not like a wart hog that is just a
little short fucking stubby neck.
It's tough to get to you.
There's a giant neck trees everywhere
rounded you could and kill
you.
I mean,
they're so happy.
They're in the zoo.
They're so happy.
No,
they don't know how happy they are.
They're like,
wait,
nothing's eating meat and this three
year olds giving me food.
Okay,
I think this is good.
But then there's,
there's weirdness when it comes to
captivated captive animals,
like,
um,
these hunting camps that they have in
Africa,
it gets again the gray area,
the weirdness of the world because,
you know,
Louis thorough the documentary guy.
Yeah.
Fascinating guy had him on the podcast.
Really,
really interesting category to watch.
That one is a good one.
One of the best documentaries that he
did was when he went to Africa and went
to these hunting camps,
they have these high fence hunting camps
where they take these animals and they
put them in these huge enclosures and
they let people hunt them.
The irony is these animals are,
there's higher populations.
They're healthier.
There's more of them.
Animals that were on the verge of
extinction are now.
There's many,
many,
many of them,
but they're hunted.
Yeah,
so it's like people have this weird sort
of like,
well yeah,
the animals are healthier,
that populations are healthier,
but the reason being is because people
can pay to go kill them.
Like whoa,
but it's just another example of the
world not being so clear cut.
There's a lot of weirdness out there.
Ironically,
the like some of the rhinos that are
left in this world are at those camps.
They're not being hunted.
There've been protected during these
high fence game fence areas where people
are coming.
They'll come look at the rhino and be
like,
Oh wow,
what a beautiful.
Righto,
righto.
All right,
let's go shoot a buck and a kudu.
How much does it cost?
You know,
like something they couldn't do 20 years
ago because there weren't enough of
them,
but no,
like,
oh limitless and Paula,
what?
That's a blessed book.
Oh,
I'll take one of those.
That's not a problem.
You know,
like that's what it's like there.
But there they saved species by making
them available to be paid for.
Yeah,
it was very strange.
And Louis Theroux is documentary really
kept his position.
Well,
his position is he's trying to get to
it.
He's trying to get to his position
during the whole documentary.
He's like,
okay,
I see,
but the real position is really clearly
established by the guy who runs the
hunting camp because he gets angry at
Louis.
One point in the show,
like,
you know,
three quarters of the way in.
He goes,
you don't understand.
Africa is fucked.
He goes,
it's fucked.
Unless something is with money,
it's gonna fucking die.
They fucking kill everything.
It's fucked.
There's nothing here that have these
fucking animals.
I here is because they're worth money.
That's it.
Do you understand?
And you know Louise,
like I guess I understand it's true.
It is true,
it is true,
and in a sense that sort of mirrors
what's going on when it comes to
wildlife in America.
More money has been spent by hunters to
conserve wetlands,
to preserve wildlife habitat,
for elk,
to preserve areas where deer live and,
and,
and to
establish clear protocols as far as how
many animals can,
can be sustained in any given location
and keep the populations healthy.
All that money comes from hunters,
which is just amazing.
It's just,
it's another one of those things.
It's like when you look at it in a clear
objective terms,
you see that this is a very complex
issue and it's not as simple as these
animals are beautiful.
We should not kill them.
Like they're beautiful.
Yeah.
You have to kill them though,
but you have to kill him.
Whoa,
right.
Sucks.
It's not really the delicious.
That's the crazy thing is.
No,
no,
it doesn't really suck.
They are delicious.
Like,
fuck man,
there's so much going on there.
And again,
that's just the way the world is the
world,
which is like this ironic contrast to
the first 10 years of my life where
like,
I didn't think what I was shooting was
beautiful because they're evil fuckers,
you know,
like now as a sportsman,
a hunter,
like I love these animals.
Which animals do you think we're evil?
Uh,
terrorists.
But when we are,
you said for the first 10 years of your
life,
you're shooting terrorist.
Ten years of my career as a shooter.
Oh,
I thought you were saying as your life
when you're nine years old at 23,
you know,
it's like no remorse.
Slept very well at night because these
were evil people and now I'm like,
Oh man,
I don't want to shoot that.
That's pretty.
Now that thing's beautiful.
That all.
Shoot,
you know,
because that is really yummy and there's
too many of them know.
Yeah.
I have a buddy who served and came back
and he loves fishing and he had a real
hard time getting back into hunting.
He said,
you know,
you just,
you see so much death at a certain point
in time,
you don't want to be a part of
empathize.
Yeah.
He,
he got back.
He lives in New Mexico and he got back
into elk hunting.
New Mexican was great for elk.
He got back into an after awhile,
but it took them awhile,
took them awhile to just sort of settle
in.
He just like,
I saw too much death.
Totally empathetic to that.
Is there ever going to be a time when
there's no war?
Is that even possible with human beings?
Not In my lifetime.
That's a disturbing idea for people
because if people have this idea,
I mean this is,
this is a shitty analogy,
but it's one that I use if 20 people can
get along,
if like,
okay,
there's five of us in this room were
four of us in this room.
If there's four people in this room and
we can get along,
can 40 people get along?
Yes.
40 people can get along.
You could have a community of 40 people
with no problems and just live from
birth to death and everybody,
you know,
nobody kills anybody that weird outlier
at 40,
but you know,
as a community that they'll absorb him
for what he is or whatever,
but then you get to 4,000.
No,
no,
someone's going to die.
Yeah,
Jim's Douche.
We've got to take out Jim,
you know,
and everybody's gonna meet by the
Campfire and go,
look,
this motherfucker is just ruining our
life.
He doesn't hunt.
He eats all her food.
He fucks are women were not there.
He beats our kids.
We've got to kill this
guy and there's one out of a certain
number.
There's going to be this one that comes
up and then when you deal with $7
million,
it's like,
Whoa,
how does,
how does that ever become manageable?
I mean to human beings have to evolve
past what we are right now.
Do we have to hope some new stage?
Yeah,
I hope so too.
Well,
you would know better than anybody what
the horrors of war are.
So would you think that someone who has
experienced that would have a better
perspective about what's necessary and
what's not necessary when it comes to
sort of just managing piece?
Try to.
Yes and no.
You know,
there's no like,
nirvana moment where you had like this
clear sight of,
you know,
what an understanding of what's
necessary and what's not,
how people should be or how people
shouldn't be.
Like if anything,
you know,
as six years as a door kicker assaulter
and then four years as a halo sniper
guy.
I've seen death like from a foot away
and from a mile away,
you know,
so like there's no range of death I
haven't seen.
So if anything,
like I value life more.
I think,
um,
I hate war more like I know,
like I think it's horrible and
disgusting,
but without a doubt I think it's
absolutely necessary and,
and
needed into such a level that I can't
even imagine what this world would be
like had we not been involved to the
degree that we've been involved in for
the past 12 years trying to eradicate
this fanatic group of psychopaths.
So I don't want to think about what the
world would be like,
but,
you know,
I don't want my,
my nieces and my nephews or my kids to
ever have to do what I did or see what I
saw.
So I dunno,
like,
um,
I hope we never have to invade a
country.
You know,
I remember we were talking about Syria.
You're like,
are we going to go over there?
I was like,
God,
no.
You know,
there's no,
there's no need.
There's no resources.
There's no necessary element for us to
be involved in.
But the preservation of human life isn't
that needed.
You know,
Brian,
I don't.
Well,
that's one of the reasons why
false flags and false flag operations
are so disgusting when you find out that
someone's lying about the motivation for
profit and that
nothing worse than somebody that lies
for the benefit of themselves.
Like Joe,
I think you're a good looking man and I
think that dress looks great on you and
it makes you look thin.
That's no k lice lie sometimes to to
tell you no,
wait,
it's your 28th birthday,
you know,
that's great to hear.
You know,
I'm 40 or whatever.
like those,
those are not self serving lizard cute
laws,
but when you're lying so that you can
put money in your pocket at the expense
of human,
I hope you burn in hell forever.
It's a dark law.
No,
it's a very,
very dark lie.
It's,
it's a.
it's a confusing lie too because it's
like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
This has actually happened.
When you find out about the Gulf of
Tonkin or operation northwoods,
that there have been these moments in
time where people have tried to figure
out a way to lie in order to drag people
into war,
a war that otherwise the public wouldn't
support.
It's a.
it's dark,
it's dark.
It's.
It's a very weird aspect of society that
it not only that exists,
but that's ignored.
It's ignored and almost brushed under
the table when you start talking about
war and about policy.
This is something that people don't want
to acknowledge,
that we have been duped by the military
industrial complex in the past and that
it is actually many standard,
standard operational procedure that they
will come up with different ways in
order to get people to support Warren.
One of them is the lie.
You know when,
when guys come back,
the big one is ptsd.
That's,
that's the the the hardest aspect.
It seems to to integrate back into a
normal society with normal life and
normal jobs and normal.
Just the things that we all just deal
with on a regular basis.
For some folks it becomes almost
unbearable.
What is the difference between people
that integrate smoothly and people that
have an incredibly difficult time,
you know,
from,
from that incredibly difficult time to
smoothly are all scales,
you know,
and the biggest or the factors are the
degrees of coping mechanisms that,
that an individual has.
I have a very strong family,
you know,
like an amazing wife.
Fantastic father and mother.
They're still married.
Amazing brother and sister.
Great.
Like so family unit.
Very supportive.
I'm very fit and very healthy.
I'm well educated as well trained.
These are all different mechanisms to
deal with stress.
Everybody deals with stress differently,
but the foundation of how you deal with
stress,
you have to have these fundamental
elements to be able to do the more of
them that you have,
the more stress you can deal with.
So a guy like me that was ranger sniper,
green baret like killed.
Lots of dudes can come back and sleep
well at night,
you know?
Yeah.
I had to adjust.
There are things that,
you know,
like I had moments where a guy smoking a
clove that may be just aided Indian
restaurant.
So I'm having some sensory to like how
he smells,
listening to music from that culture
that I just spent six,
six months with,
you know,
like I'm like,
I want to shoot this person,
like that instant reaction.
But then I'm like,
okay,
know everything's okay.
I'm wow.
What is that like?
It's weird.
I was walking into a best buy and that
was an example.
This guy driving a yellow bmw,
you're smoking a clove and I got this
width of like curry and so everything
was there.
Like the music,
the look what he was wearing,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
like I was just like,
fuck,
it looks like a terrorist,
a snap judgment.
Like I just got back a couple of days,
letter later and I was like,
should I shoot this person?
No,
I'm in Fayetteville,
North Carolina.
Walk into a best buy to buy the new
avengers movie.
Now there was iron man.
I remember what it was.
But you were an educated
guy and you're intelligent in respect of
introspective guy for a guy who's not.
That's the problem with those coping
mechanisms.
Like how much does that person have?
You have a national guardsman that
enlisted out of high school,
him comes from a broken home.
He's poor,
you know,
then he goes,
he,
he enlisted to be a truck driver and
then his truck gets blown up and they
get in a firefight and then he sees
death.
He saw the guy that has navigator,
just lost an arm.
Did that guy is scarred for life.
You know,
he has no kept coping mechanisms deal.
And then he comes home and he's broken
and he's damaged,
you know,
like,
how,
how does that person reintegrate into
society without all the necessary coping
mechanisms?
Man,
it's hard.
Um,
when you hear it
about stories where guys snap and uh,
there,
there've been several over the course of
these two wars and one of the big ones
was uh,
a decorated guy want killing a bunch of
civilians and it made,
made a lot of the rounds on these talk
shows or people trying to discuss like
ptsd and traumatic events and that this
guy was,
he was having real problems and
reporting,
having real problems before all this
happened.
And they kept sending him back over
there.
Do you,
do you relate to that and you try to try
to figure it out for yourself?
Like when you see these stories in the
news,
like how did they hit you?
Um,
I wish I could be empathetic to like
I've had ptsd nightmares where I wake up
in a sweat,
you know,
and like I put my,
my hand through the wall,
you know,
my wife's like,
are you okay?
You know,
like that was years ago when I first
came back after,
you know,
some bad rough trips.
Um,
so maybe I have some empathy to that,
but I'm,
the special forces unit by design is
very tight and you know,
like if you're having issues I can go to
my team sergeant or I can go to my
senior and bounce things off off of
them.
I get really resentful over people
making snap judgments about these guys
that are coming back and having issues,
you know,
like,
Oh,
you're a veteran.
Is it safe for my kids to be around,
you know,
like hell yeah.
They're like the greatest human beings
on the planet.
You don't like one in a million,
have not one was a very small percentage
have serious issues,
but we have to have our eyes wide open
about how to deal with posttraumatic
stress and um,
there's not one easy solution and it's a
lot of hard work to get there.
It's not one easy solution.
There's not one standard set of
experiences that each veteran
experiences over there and brings back
with them.
It's all,
it varies.
And that's such an important thing that
you said about the coping mechanisms
that you have in place.
What,
what's done to,
to help veterans when,
when,
when they come back as far as like help
them strengthen their coping
mechanisms,
help them deal with situations.
What kind of support did they offer you?
So now,
you know,
we've been at war for a long time.
We have a lot of things in place where,
you know,
frg the family readiness group is there
for your family.
So when you're coming back that your
family has an understanding of what
you've experienced or how to deal with
you,
you know,
like,
um,
you know,
not,
hey,
Saturday,
you're going to be coaching kids
softball Saturday night,
you know,
we have this,
we're going to mom and dad's for,
you know,
they're not like overwhelming you with
like American life,
which is normal to everybody else,
unless you've been in a plywood building
for 12 months and now you're back
surrounded without like thousands of
people that you have no idea.
It's weird.
Um,
so the military has done a way better
job of trying to reintegrate soldiers
back into normal life.
But then you have a lot of great
organizations that are,
that are veteran started.
And these guys really get it.
You know,
like,
I'm Brian.
Stan is great example.
Hire heroes.
You know,
he's involved with getting these guys
back to work.
Um,
veterans outdoors,
like a make wish foundation for wounded
guys.
So like if you have a serious physical
ailment from battle,
whether it's internal or physical,
um,
they'll give you these crazy things just
to be like,
hey,
things are okay.
You're still surrounded by friends,
let's get you reconnected to a community
that you're involved with and do
something fun at the same time.
So there's a lot of different ways.
Like the worst thing though is when they
start throwing pills at these guys,
um,
you know,
the pharmaceutical approach.
Whereas like,
alright,
let's put you on an antidepressant and
hope for the best.
There's a lot of that freaking retarded
when,
when you're over there,
do they try to offer it to when you're
actually in country?
Uh,
not,
not like antidepressants,
you know,
there,
there's pharmaceutical things like to
keep you awake longer,
to make you alert long.
I've had just like,
you're in special forces.
I,
Hey,
here's,
you know this.
Well,
I mean even,
even some great stuff,
we're like over the counter things like
I wish I had alpha brain when I was
there,
like,
not,
not plugging intentionally,
but like,
that stuff's fantastic.
You're focused,
you feel good,
you're ready to go.
You know,
that would have been a thousand times
better than,
you know,
like,
Hey,
here's,
here's something that God just sent down
for us to use.
You know,
it's,
it'll keep you awake for three days.
Awesome.
What did they give you?
What?
I don't have no idea.
You didn't even know what they were?
Not really,
but I know I was awake for three days.
You know,
I have friends who went over there and
said they just gave him steroids.
They gave him oral steroids.
Why do you want,
I've never done steroids.
Like I swear by law is holy and true.
Um,
the where they offered an available.
Yeah.
You know,
but we have a special forces guy.
He's 38 years old.
This is his sixth,
seventh combat tour.
We're doing two,
three,
four hits and night a hits like
missions.
You know,
we're doing mission followup,
mission followup mission.
We're doing a helicopter landing.
We're doing a gap where we're on a
ground assault force.
And um,
this guy is broken.
He's hurt.
His physically can't keep up joint.
He needs it,
you know.
And do I want to like,
do I want the 38 year old dude next to
me that's on steroids or do I want the
one that can barely walk because
everything hurts so bad?
Uh,
oh,
with a 38 year old on steroids.
Yeah.
And that sort of brings up what we were
talking about before where it's the,
the discussion of tea,
our tea when it comes to a mixed martial
arts training,
a testosterone replacement therapy for
sewer.
Yeah.
For folks who don't know this,
this debate,
they're not mixed martial arts fans and
now there's probably a lot of people
listening to this that aren't,
um,
for a long time,
over a year,
two years,
whatever it was,
you were allowed to get prescribed
testosterone.
And Brendan Schaub said it best when
we're discussing it on the podcast,
he said that there's,
there's youth and with youth you have
elevated hormone levels,
but you have a lack of experience.
You have a lack of knowledge.
And then as you get older you get wiser,
you get smarter,
you have more knowledge,
but the body just does not respond the
way it used to.
And Eve Edwards was talking to him and
he was saying,
you know,
man,
he's like 37 now.
And he's like,
I know so much now,
but my body just doesn't listen,
just doesn't,
doesn't do what it did when I was 20 and
I didn't know as much and that this is
the name of Eve.
That's great guy.
But there's that nature balance that is
sort of stopped and it's placed with
injections of testosterone and then
you're introducing this weird element
into one of the most dangerous sports
competitions the world has ever known.
Mixed martial arts.
One of the most.
There's more on the line as far as your
emotions.
Your physical body is at risk.
There's always.
And you're sort of.
You're changing nature.
You're making it so that these old wise
people now are Jews to the gills and
they can train 17 hours a fucking day
and it gets real weird.
It gets real weird.
One that's for awhile was accepted by
athletic commissions.
Yeah.
The youth is wasted on the young,
you know,
like that expression is like you have
now,
you know,
I'm 34.
I've been doing martial arts for
forever.
I want the body of a 22 year old with
what I know now.
Right now,
but I can chemically do that,
you know,
with through testosterone,
which is what guys have been able to do
for the past couple of years and it's
dangerous,
you know,
like in,
in,
uh,
if it was golf,
I wouldn't care,
you know,
if it's baseball and like Sam was Sammy
Sosa,
mark mcgwire era.
I don't really care,
but we're in a sport where we're hitting
each other in the face and choking each
other unconscious.
Um,
we do not need the advantage of taking
the years of experience of doing martial
arts for 20 some odd years and then
giving us bodies of 20 year olds,
um,
the physicality,
the recovery,
the responsiveness.
It's,
it's horrible.
You guys have been doing it.
And now we're at this,
this,
this juncture where we're now saying,
okay,
it's not okay.
Like you can't have an athletic
commission allow you to do it.
So does that mean the guys are going to
do it on the side and do orally?
So they don't because they know where
they're going to get tested or now
they're not being monitored.
So there's going to do it whenever and
however they want.
Like what does that mean?
It's.
It's scary.
It is.
It's weird because there were a few guys
that were on it for several years and
they were being very successful while
they were on it and then all of a sudden
it gets pulled away.
So what do they do?
Do they try to bring their body up to
natural levels?
See,
but that takes time.
It takes a long time.
Yeah,
for like a,
I don't know,
let's say a hypothetical 37 year old
that's been on testosterone for four or
five years and then he can't have it
anymore.
It's going to take that guy a long time
if ever,
to be able to naturally produce
testosterone
and he'll never have the levels that he
had when he was.
No,
because the levels he's had when he was
on it for 25 year olds levels and the.
The other thing is the things that you
can take to bring your levels back up or
also banned things like clomid and all
these different.
Their estrogen or estrogen suppressing
devices.
These all these different chemicals that
people do post steroids cycle are also
illegal,
so it becomes like that was what I'm
Dennis seaver got popped for.
He got popped for one of these posts,
steroids cycle things and now he's on
the shelf for nine months because of
this.
People are like,
wait,
why was that guy?
He failed a drug test because he's
blocking estrogen.
Yeah,
you have to or otherwise you're going to
grow breasts after you've been using
anabolic steroids and testosterone.
It's like you have to,
when you will see there's there's
testosterone replacement.
Like if you went to a doctor and you
said,
Hey doc,
I'm 60 years old.
I would like to get on some testosterone
and have a better quality of life.
The doctor will give you a slow dose of
testosterone slowly ramp you up.
He's not gonna,
Bam,
Jack you and turn you into a 20 year
old,
but with a lot of fighters are doing is
they're taking way more than you would
have when you were 20 and what happens
is your body goes,
what the fuck is going on?
And it grows tits.
Literally,
your body starts producing massive
amounts of estrogen to counteract a
massive amounts of testosterone in your
body,
gets so confused as to these levels of
hormones that are completely
supernatural in your body and under
those conditions,
under those conditions,
you develop bitch tits and a lot of guys
have had them and you'll see this weird
like thing that you see these jelly like
growing around their nipples.
And I've seen guys,
whether they bounce up and down in the
cage and they're there,
they have tents.
It's
remarkable to me where people don't
understand like we're a pugilistic
sport,
like guys are trying to take every
advantage,
every shortcut that they possibly can,
you know,
like you and I can look into dude and we
like just from the texture of his skin.
Um,
can know,
like if he's on a cycle,
if he's off a cycle,
if he was on a cycle,
you know,
like the texture of their skin.
You mean like Zits on the asked me for
acne scarring or what's possible that
they have that naturally possible.
Some guys,
you know,
it is a sign,
and then they have bitched hits another
sign,
another clue,
you know,
or like a guy looked one way five years
ago when he was 32 and now he's 37 and
he looks 10,
10,000
times better than he ever has in his
whole entire life.
You're talking about Vito Belfort?
No,
I'm just kidding.
I'm just giving you an example of
perhaps another clue.
Yes,
I am.
Just so we're not being unclear about
that.
Talk about what we were talking about
before the show or is that the offer?
No,
no.
Okay.
So you know,
he,
he was the,
he's a scapegoat I think a little bit
for trt because there's a bigger problem
for the,
you know,
for the entire sport where a,
he in my opinion just personified a
problem and then you know,
everybody like pinned everything on him.
But it was a big problem throughout the
whole entire sports which is performance
enhancing drugs.
And is it right for a 37 year old dude
like theater bell for it to be on
testosterone for five years,
look amazing and fantastic while he's on
it and nothing like he did five years
ago where he was struggling,
you know,
like winning a fight,
losing a fight when now,
now he's like knocking guys out with
crazy fight of the night,
fight of the year,
like knockout of the night,
knock out of the year type stuff.
Um,
you know,
you can't have that turnaround.
And then like stopped testosterone and
two months later he's ready to go.
No,
that's chemical,
you know,
like,
that doesn't work that way.
How does a guy get off of it in that
short of a time and then have the
ability to compete again?
It would seem like it would take like a
year to just,
if ever.
Yeah.
Chemically.
There's no way around it.
No,
there's,
I,
I'm,
I'm not a doctor,
you know.
But having been a professional athlete
for 13 years,
I've never seen somebody that was so
responsive to testosterone like,
like he was.
And then come clean and try to be an
athlete like he like they wore when they
are using performance enhancing drugs
afterwards and just like miraculously
been as good as they were when they are
on.
It never has never happened.
I can't,
I can't think of like a single sport,
a single sportsmen in history where they
got popped.
They are watched closely and then
performed as well after that point.
You know,
ever.
Yeah.
I completely agree with you that it's so
different than baseball and all these
other things.
What I don't like about the baseball,
a steroid controversy is that a young
kid
who's coming up who wants to play
baseball almost has to do it in order to
compete.
So when there's a guy like Mark Mcguire
who's juice to the gills crushing the
ball out of the stadium,
a young guy coming up that wants to be
like Mark Mcguire,
most likely,
unless you have incredible genetics and
genetic specimen,
just a weird freak of nature.
Some,
you know,
some,
some guy was just the extreme mesomorph
you'll probably knock it ever be able to
do that.
And uh,
yeah,
that,
that to me sucks that a young guy has to
risk his endocrine system and put it in.
But there's such a big difference
between that and a combat sport.
Yeah.
I don't know what the solution is.
Testing,
testing right around testing random
testing in fight camp post-fight,
you know,
like right now,
um,
you know,
fought two weeks ago.
I'm getting back into training two,
three times a day.
Like this is when you,
this is when a guy test them,
test them,
you know,
like,
just show up high.
Yeah.
Joe Silva is about to throw an offer,
you know,
my way,
let's say in to fight and 10 weeks,
he knows he's gonna throw it off from my
way before he throws the off from my
way,
a guy from the athletic commission to
the respective state that I'm going to
be fighting in shows up and says,
Hey,
pee in the cup.
Um,
that's how you're going to get a fair,
equal system,
you know,
not where you sit.
Tell a guy in Brazil,
hey,
you need to come up here and take a drug
test.
And he's like,
Oh yeah man,
I'll be there.
And like four days.
No,
no dude,
like athletic commission guy shows up
the randomly and.
Right they're feeding of the cup
and when you catch someone it can't.
I think it should be more than nine
months and you know,
I think in this day and age you should
let everybody know,
hey look,
we're going to cut you.
You're not going to fight for this
organization anymore.
And let them know and then just say,
this is the rule.
This is,
this is where we're at right now.
So everyone's been served.
Notice everyone knows what the
repercussions are of this illegal
activity that puts people in jeopardy.
My real concern is medical science is
not going to stop medical science and
the.
The innovative.
Yeah,
the,
the way guys are going to sleep,
not just cheap but just the things that
they're going to come up with to,
to change the human body.
There's restorative capabilities of new
advancements and new techniques.
Like you could say that like getting in
that cryo chamber.
If you can do that cryo chamber and
another guy can't do that cryo chamber,
do you have an advantage?
Is it an unfair advantage?
You know,
where do you draw the line?
Because should you be able to take
creatine will create a teen's legal?
Doesn't that increase muscle power?
And it does,
it increases your ability to work
harder.
It's like,
where is the line?
Can you take tribulus can you take on
it's t plus we're having great results
with that t plus stuff where guys are
showing he's 50 percent increases in,
in,
in rates of lifting,
and they're there the rate of progress
over people that are not taking it and
double blind placebos.
Like what?
When,
when do you,
when does it become legal and when it's
become cheating,
when is it like a nice supplement and
when is it a performance enhancing drug?
I think one of the big things is what
does it do to your body in the long run?
You know,
when you're using it as a supplement,
we'll just call them all supplements
that will just even remove performance
enhancing drugs from,
from,
uh,
the discussion,
just a supplement that does in the short
term great benefits in the long term,
big damage.
You know,
when you have wwe stars that are dying
at 41 from heart attacks,
you know,
and Lo and behold,
they've been doing steroids for 12
years.
You know,
it's,
it's tragic.
It's sad,
but not
pricing isn't a lot of those guys that
the pain pills,
those guys are folks who don't respect
pro wrestlers either.
I know a lot of people think that,
oh,
it's all fake.
Silly.
Those guys work hard at is image their
bodies all the time.
If you watch those guys flying through
the air and jumping on each other,
that's not a free ride.
They're getting hurt all the time.
And a huge problem in that world is guys
that get hooked on pain pills,
man.
Well the damage
body,
but then they have a show next Saturday.
They have to like,
you know,
Mcmahon's like,
no,
you got to perform bro.
That's like you're your own contract.
You're going to get paid.
Like,
I can't move my hands right now.
Like I can't use my fingers.
All right,
well take this,
you know,
now everything doesn't hurt and you'll
be able to perform
because that's what's important.
Yeah.
Becomes like a thing where there's,
there's things that you can take that
elevate your body's natural production
of testosterone and they,
they can enhance your body's production,
but what they don't do is introduced
synthetic versions of it that shut down
your endocrine system.
What they don't do is give you these
hyper human levels that are causing you
to grow tits.
You know,
there's,
there's got to be like a comfortable
medium between eating healthy,
having benefits like the cryo chamber
and all these different things that do
enhance recovery.
But don't put you in your body in
danger.
Don't burn you out in the short term,
you know,
to give you the rest of your life.
You're,
you're fucked.
You know,
from 35 on,
your body's just devastated.
It's,
it's not going to be black and white.
You know,
it's not going to be a line drawn in the
sand,
you know,
that line needs to be able to be moved,
it needs to have commissions and medical
professionals that can adjust and adapt
to what's happening,
you know,
with the growth of science,
like there's a reason why we're breaking
records every Olympics.
We're getting better,
you know,
like with the human body,
how to make it perform better.
I'm having people that are smarter than
me,
like figure out where those lines are
and move them so that you don't have to
get that line,
has to be there,
you know,
um,
it can be a mobile line that they,
they move,
you know,
from year to year.
But that line has to be there.
And when guys step across it,
um,
you know,
there has to be recut repercussions.
My concern is what's really going to
happen in the future,
which happens with almost anything that
involves human innovation.
Like if you look back at the cell phones
of the 19 nineties where they had these
fucking giant bricks and they'd hold
them up to the head and have videos and
now you can go anywhere in the world in
a third world country,
in a impoverished neighborhood,
and people have these really small,
incredibly complex cell phones that are
just these magical devices that allow
you to interface with the entire
knowledge base of the world and they're.
They're everywhere.
I wonder what's going to happen when you
have the kind of technology that they're
working on right now,
genetic engineering at a,
at a cellular level where they're able
to change people.
I mean,
I'm sure you're aware of the mild stat
inhibitors like these things that they
use with.
Well,
they've demonstrated in whippets.
These dogs were just because of
breeding.
Just a just a mistake and breeding.
They've produced these super hyper
muscular dogs that have double the
muscle in cows as well.
Have you ever seen those images?
It's incredible,
right?
Well,
people are being born just born with it.
A kid in Germany was born just a genetic
mistake or,
or a benefit to him.
Well,
they're gonna be able to figure that out
with a pill or the shot and you're
fucking mailman is going to have it.
Your mailman is gonna.
Look like the hulk.
And when that happens,
when it's everywhere,
what is,
what do we do with athletes?
Have the Germans were trying it with
your genetics.
You know,
like we've done it periodically
throughout history.
The spartans did it,
you know,
they did it at spartans do.
They'd throw babies that didn't meet
their requirements off the cliff.
Yeah.
This huge genetics at a very primal
level of it happens in nature all the
time where a mom will be like,
this cup is not gonna be able to walk.
I'm leaving it,
you know?
So like,
that's your genetics.
That's survival of the fittest.
Now we as super too smart for our own
good.
Sometimes humans can take huge genetics
and fix it with chemistry.
That's scary.
You know,
where we can just magically pop out like
superhuman.
I don't.
I don't know if I'm ready for that.
I don't know anyone's ready for the
implications of what that means morally.
If we don't get hit by an asteroid or
invaded by aliens or blow each other up
with nukes,
it's common there.
They're not going to stop.
There's egg heads that are in
laboratories right now that are
constantly working on new shit and
that's what they do and that's what
humans do.
We push the boundaries of innovation.
We always have.
It's part of what makes us human.
It's why we're on a podcast right now
talking to a microphone that neither you
nor I could have ever figured out on her
own.
It's just a part of the program and
they're going to figure out something,
man.
They're going to inject you with Nano
bots or some sort of a new chemical that
allows your body to work like Spiderman.
I mean,
you're going to fucking climb walls.
You're gonna.
You're going to have incredible balance.
They're going to figure out a way to
stop traumatic brain injury by
reengineering the human mind.
This is going to be a of crazy shit.
It might not be in our lifetimes,
but are killed.
Our Children's children for sure are
going to experience human beings that no
one has ever experienced in the entire
history of the,
of the world itself.
It's coming,
it's coming by human innovation.
It's gonna,
leapfrog,
evolution.
I'm not sure I want to.
I'm going to kind of sad that I'm going
to miss it.
Maybe I want to reap the benefits of it,
but then at the flip,
I don't want to have to deal with,
uh,
the,
you know,
the implications of that.
I'm sad that I'm going to miss it too.
Or we might not miss it.
We might just catch the wave,
but I'm also,
I'm glad that I saw the world before.
A lot of shit was.
They're like,
my kids are gonna grow up in a world.
I have a 17 year old and she doesn't
have any idea what life was like before
the Internet.
She has no idea.
The Internet is always been there.
She has a question.
Oh,
there's the answer.
I grew up.
I was retarded when I was her age and I
put it in her head every day I go,
let me tell you,
if you met me,
if I was 17 and you were 17,
you would think,
oh my God,
this is the dumbest fucking guy that's
ever walked the face of the earth,
and he thinks he's so smart.
I was an idiot.
I knew how to throw kicks and I knew
which Stephen King books I liked.
That's it.
I knew what the right combination of
words to say to get a girl to fuck me
sometimes.
That's it.
That's all I knew.
I was a moron.
Like what a 17 year old knows today as
opposed to what they knew when I was.
Now the future is going to be even
crazier than that,
but at least I got a perspective.
I got to see what it was like to grow up
where you didn't know if you called
someone and they weren't home.
They just weren't fucking home.
You know?
I remember when answering machines were
invented where people were like,
Holy Shit
again,
the Internet and you'd hear this,
and it was slow.
As fuck,
and if you wanted to see a picture of
something or be like click,
click,
white and green.
Yeah.
Variations of those three.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I remember when Internet searches first
came about to when you first find.
I got a great story.
There was a,
we don't even need to say the name of
the organization,
but a buddy of mine used to be co owner
of a small mixed martial arts
organization and this was in the late
nineties and they were just starting to
promote fighters through the Internet
and they were just starting to do bios
where they would research a guy through
the internet where they researched this
guy and they find out that a guy with
the exact same name,
one something called the hungry as but
contest.
Oh No.
So they're,
they're gladiator there.
Heavyweight,
there,
Adonis,
six foot four,
shredded man with his penthouse pet
girlfriend,
you know,
that he would parade around at all these
events.
Also had done gay porn.
And so,
uh,
they pulled down the picture,
these downloads and pictures,
and my friend described as like,
Isi,
click,
you know,
have those pictures would slowly show up
on a 56 k modem.
It would like,
you would get the top of it and it would
slowly start to pan down.
And as it pans now what that looks like,
his hair,
click the click that looks like it could
be his forehead.
Click well that's his eyes.
Click,
click,
click.
That's dig in his mouth.
Oh my God.
And this is a ticket his ass.
There was two guys using him like
Chinese finger handcuffs.
And they're like,
whoa.
And so this dude had no idea that,
that was even possible to internet.
He'd used the same name,
you know,
he just figured and no one is going to
look that up.
But homos.
And then they did.
Yeah.
When they said,
you know,
he needed a lot of money and they gave
him some money.
So he did it once.
Turn.
I did like 100 films,
you know,
it was a lot.
He's doing really good.
How good could it be?
The joke is I would say,
you know,
what is a lot of money mean to you?
A lot of money to me means I do one gay
porno and I live like in a video for the
rest of my life and I'm in my underwear
with two bottles of cristal on a yacht
with a thousand models forever.
That's.
We did 100 porns.
He should have all the money on the
planet by my calculations.
There's no one Richard ever anywhere.
And it fucking is con fuck everyone has
ever lived.
Has got.
Who's got money?
That guy would have all the money.
Every country would be bankrupt and this
guy's bank account would have all the
cash.
Yeah,
but the thing is it's just like no one
knew before that,
that an internet search was a
possibility.
And think about how many people that
have done things that just had no idea
what you're going to be able to find
that out.
Like how could and now and find it out
on your phone just.
Yep.
And be able to access the person that
said content is about like,
no,
never in our history in May kinds
existence have we been able to connect
so effortlessly to so many different
people,
you know,
like,
like a fan that doesn't like me.
You can just get on twitter and like
tell me that I'm a baby killer.
Like just because,
you know,
or they can do anything anytime,
anywhere and they can,
you know,
like you can find out anything about
anybody and then probably breached that
person,
especially a fighter or someone who's
got a social media account or a
president of a social media account.
You know,
like there's a few folks that I know
that just avoid it all together,
but they don't have to do it.
50 million people here,
like almost all of them,
like $300
and Mexicans,
14 account Mexicans.
It's probably another 50 million a
lease.
I don't know.
Who knows how many.
I love Mexicans,
don't get me wrong,
but there's a lot of them that aren't
taking the census.
Um,
how often do you get fucked with on
social media?
All the time.
All the time
I,
I guess I'm like a polarizing figure.
I don't know how I think I'm a likable
guy,
but some for some reason
people have a problem with strength.
People have a problem with competence.
People have a problem with,
with folks that have strong opinions or
controversial opinions,
and instead of those,
well,
you know,
you should.
I think anybody who's paying attention
to the world and sees all the
contradictory information that we're
receiving,
sees the chaos,
sees,
just sees how fucked our political
system is.
Our financial system.
If you don't have strong opinions,
if you don't have controversial
opinions,
you're not paying attention to your
eyes.
You know?
I mean,
I can't tell you how many conversations
I've had about gun control just about
guns itself.
I'm like,
God damn,
guns aren't the problem.
It's people that use guns that are the
problem.
You leave,
uh,
you know,
that old adage,
guns don't kill people.
People kill people and people will
fucking argue that to the end of time.
God dammit.
It's true.
Every time you go to the gas station,
you got a store in that gas station that
sells the lighters.
You got fluid that comes out of a pump
and anyone can just light people on
fire.
I mean it's it.
Anyone can do it.
It hasn't happened that often,
but anyone can do it.
Or just take your car and turn two
degrees to the right and run down the
sidewalk.
Yeah.
The,
the option to kill is always there.
It's always there.
It's a choice,
you know?
And they're like,
but it's a tool.
It's a mechanism that serves no other
purpose.
You know,
a car can get you from point a to point
b.
So why do they need a gun with him?
The only thing it does is kill you.
Like I could say the same thing about a
tractor.
If I wanted to know,
like if I wanted to make a killer
tractor,
the only thing that's designed for us to
kill because I put spikes on its wheels,
you know,
and it's not,
doesn't excavate anything besides human
souls,
but no,
it's the choice to kill,
you know,
it's like get over it.
Get people killed
it is is a way that they can do it
easily and that is an issue,
but
it's also why does a person have the
ability to do that and how come so
little effort and so little emphasis is
on what causes a person to be able to
disconnect or to be able to have so much
hate and anger in their heart that they
can kill a bunch of school children,
that they can use a gun to shoot up a
mall like,
wow,
why isn't that the subject of discussion
and why is it always the tool for
madness?
It's not the madness itself is the tool
of madness,
but that same tool can be used by anyone
else to do a million other things.
It's like it's a bad analogy,
but it's one that I always use with
marijuana.
People go,
Oh,
you could ruin your life if you smoke
pot.
You could.
You could also take a hammer and hit
yourself in the Dick.
You know,
should.
Should we make hammers illegal?
Because you can.
Because the hammer is just a tool.
If you take marijuana and just enjoy it
and you don't hurt anybody,
should that person be penalized because
someone decided to just wake and bake
every day and then fucking go into debt
and wind up.
It's humans are the problem in human
weakness and a lack of character and all
sorts of chemical imbalances
or the culture and the structure around
the person that led them to make these
horrific decisions and actions.
You know,
that they use whatever tool,
don't care what it is,
gun knife,
everything up to that point is what we
should.
The emphasis of trying to understand or
prevent an acknowledged and research
should be done,
not take away,
you know,
whatever it was.
That was the end conclusion.
It's all the things up to that point
that's that are important that nobody
pays attention to,
nobody cares about.
That's what was ridiculous about it.
Any sort of control,
gun control,
knife control,
bow and Arrow control debate.
It's not that.
It's what constitutes what went,
what makes a human being capable of
horrific things,
and I think you're uniquely qualified
for a bunch of reasons.
One,
because you have a family,
you know what it's like to raise a
person and to.
You've seen the consequences of human
beings when they're in this environment
that is totally fucked from from the
jump and you see these religious
fanatics and you see fundamentalism,
you see chaos and a land that's just
just overrun with it.
You see it's.
It's humans.
It's the development of humans
and an error.
They use the development erroneously,
like the development of human,
the wrong way.
There's the right way and there's not.
There's the right way.
There's about a billion right ways.
Yeah,
there's a couple of wrong ways,
you know,
in a couple of wrong ways,
end up with bad products
and it's again,
it's sort of contradictory thing that
through through combat and through,
especially through martial arts,
I think that the deepest bond of
commitment that I've ever experienced
was outside of my family is the friends
that have trained with and people that
have competed with that,
that have just.
You see them.
You know who the fuck they are.
When you see a guy breaking training,
when you see a guy with 30 seconds to go
in the ground,
put his hands down on his knees and just
take deep breaths and step away,
and then you see the coach go get back
in there and you see them suck it up and
you know,
there's the guys who would suck it up
and it's guys who don't and you see the
difference,
you see who they are,
you see their soul,
you see,
and you learn about people that way in a
way that a lot of folks don't ever get a
chance to learn even about themselves.
The refiner fire,
the refiner's fire is like this
beautiful thing.
You know,
it's a refiner's fire.
Refiner's fire.
Yeah.
So get you take a metal refineries.
Right.
Okay.
When you're making a sword,
you know,
the,
the folding process of heating it up and
pounding out the impurities and 14 and
again,
and pounding out the impurities.
Impurities.
Like the hotter the fire,
the more bad stuff gets cooked out.
Um,
that's the same with people.
You know,
you put them in a room that's hot,
put them in a Ge that's hot.
I'm around a whole bunch of other dudes
that are like trying to choke each other
out and kill you.
You get glimpses of the depth and
hardness of somebody's character and
soul and see awesome snapshots and even
kids like down at the youngest level,
putting them into competitions of
martial arts.
You see the exact same thing.
You see the development of this
character and if somebody's soul,
as they get tougher and deeper,
you know,
as a,
as a human,
and you get in indy snapshots,
you get a clear glimpse of who that
person is,
what's,
what's part of them.
Like it's cool,
it's cool.
Strong Gracie said it best.
He said,
uh,
you know,
I,
I reserve judgment until I've trained
with you.
Now he said,
I think you know me.
You know,
you seem like a nice guy,
but I reserve judgment until I've
trained with you,
which is such a great way to put it.
And you know,
a lot of people think we're cool.
I don't want a fucking train.
You don't have to.
It's not that it's just you should in
your life do something difficult.
It is not martial arts.
Maybe it's mountain climbing,
maybe it's hiking.
Maybe I'd run anything.
Doesn't matter.
Do something that's hard to do.
Maybe it's write a book.
Find out what your fucking barriers are
because the most reprehensible thing,
the thing that we all pretty much
universally despised is a spoiled rich
kid,
a spoiled kid that never had to work for
anything.
They were handed at their whole life,
their parents never gave them values,
and what did they do?
They grow up yelling at servants and
then they become some rich asshole.
That's a sociopath.
I mean that is the.
That's.
That's a key character in so many movies
that's in so many books,
literature,
we all can relate to that person who
didn't earn it,
who got that place without hard work and
how gross they are.
I hate that pussy.
Fucking everybody does.
You're supposed to.
It's supposed to.
They're not supposed to be there.
It's not supposed to happen.
You're not supposed to win the lottery
like that.
That fucks you up.
But the really remarkable ones that are
the ones that could or have access to
all of that and then choose not to,
or on the total flip side,
the guys that have access to none of
that and challenge themselves and put
themselves through hardships that the
altos,
you know,
that like they have nothing.
And just through hard work
determination,
they become something,
you know,
like those are two complete polar
opposites of a human that I just like,
I adore.
You know,
like I said in the military,
you see these guys are like,
you were like this Ivy League,
Super Rich,
you're enlisted.
Why are you here?
You know,
you could have done anything.
They're like,
I wanted to be here.
Like I love you.
You're amazing.
You know.
And then then the flip side,
you know,
the,
the Puerto Rican that his parents swam
over here or on some pourable boat and
um,
you know,
they're one generation removed and they
have like they put themselves through
college or maybe they joined the
military so they could go to college and
their ethics,
this exact same point of their life as
this rich Yuppie guy that are just there
because they want to see how hard they
are,
how far they can push themselves.
Yeah.
Humans beings are just,
we are just a mass of potential and it's
awesome to see someone rise through
adversity and reach a potential that
elevates us all.
Because when you see someone reach their
potential or reach out very high level
of,
of anything,
it changes the way you look at what's
possible.
When you see a guy who gets up at 6:00
in the morning,
the alarm clock goes off and he just
fucking hits those hills and starts
running and he does it every morning
before work.
You Go,
fuck,
I'm a bitch.
I'm just a weak bitch.
I don't do that.
Fuck.
And then it changes your perspective.
You want to do that too.
You want to absorb a little bit of that
guy strengthened that feeling that you
get from being around that guy.
It's empowering or you're one of those
guys that diminishes that and tries to
squash it because you're insecure and
you wanna you wanna tweet,
Tim Kennedy,
you fucking bitch.
You look you in the mood to you mean,
you know there's,
there's folks like that too.
I think that strength is the best
antidote for a lot of the weaknesses
that we find in our society that we
consider to be strength.
Like bullies.
People say like,
what's the best solution to bullies?
Teach them how to fight.
Teach them all how to fight everyone.
I think that is a core problem with men.
Men have a giant fear hanging over their
head all day long and that is being
dominated by other men.
You know,
I mean is what led me to martial arts
100 percent was I was scared of dudes
kicking my ass.
So I got into martial arts as a very
young kid because of that.
And I think that the more kids,
if we had programs in school where we
taught martial arts to kids in class,
you would have so few instances of
bullying.
I think the dramatic decrease in
bullying and the respect that people
have for each other would change the
respect that people have for themselves.
Like a bully cannot respect themselves.
They just can't.
Unless there's some sort of a complete
sociopath.
You're not,
you're,
you're not going to be happy with
yourself if you pick on someone smaller
than you,
you're doing it because you're insecure.
But if you weren't insecure or you were
less insecure or you had some sort of
sense of personal sovereignty because of
training,
you would have less of this,
this inclination to do something shitty
to someone like that.
Yeah,
it'd be cool to see.
Fuck him,
man.
I think martial arts programs should be
mandatory in school,
just like they have pes mandatory for.
For Boys,
especially martial arts should be.
And you want to.
You want to see what you want to see
your kid have discipline,
focus,
understanding of,
right and wrong.
A little bit of confidence.
Restraint,
martial arts,
that's why you did it.
So you didn't get beat up.
I,
I did it because,
um,
our second born,
I was a crazy middle kid,
you know,
my dad's like at a very early age like
you are going to be doing martial arts,
you know,
so like I was like nine.
And I remember saying a bad word on the
mat and having,
you know,
my,
my sensei come up with an a scream of
stick and hit me in the back of the head
and like I'm,
I missed up and doing stuff.
And he's like,
ah.
And then I said a bad word when I messed
up.
And then bow,
you're like,
I didn't say that bad word again.
And,
but more importantly I was able to
control myself,
which was the elements,
the necessary element that I needed.
And also this,
the great feeling of accomplishment that
you get when you learn that you can
control yourself.
When you feel yourself improving,
your feel,
your character improving and you have a
difficult situation and you navigate it
successfully.
And he goes,
oh,
I'm a better person now than I was when
I was whatever,
when I was young and stupid.
And that's just one of those things
where everybody wants to be comfortable.
Everybody wants to look towards their
golden age and everybody wants to retire
and sit on the couch and put your feet
up.
That's horseshit.
That's not you.
You only.
You only can experience that and enjoy
it if you've earned it.
No one wants to earn it.
The earning is the most important part
of your life.
Individual risks,
possibility.
Nobody has it.
You've got to earn it.
You've got to work for it.
You gotta you know so much better when
you do.
Yes.
Well,
that's why I think guys like you were
important,
man.
I think you set a great example of that.
I think you said a great example with
your words.
I think you set a great example with
your actions.
It's one of the reasons why I've been
wanting to talk to you on the podcast.
You're a very inspirational guy in my
opinion.
I think you,
the way you talk about things and the
way you express yourself,
it's,
it's admirable and I think it,
it helps people,
it,
it sets a very high standard and I think
setting a high standard is one of the
key things that young men and young,
I'm sure young women as well need in
life.
They need to see a high standard.
I'm not perfect.
I make mistakes probably way too much or
more often than I'd like to admit,
but I'm always searching and seeking to
get better know,
like,
and I think that's something that I
always tried to project.
Um,
you know,
and the only way to get theirs is like
you've just said,
it's,
it's through hard work.
It's through determination.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's through the amazing innate part of
the human being,
which is the ability to do,
you know,
and to not quit and to have the inner
strength to try to achieve and surpass
whatever it was before.
And there's beauty in imperfection.
You know,
this idea that you're going to be this
enlightened,
quite Chang Kang character electing the
TV show.
You got to take a leak.
Good head on.
I saw you drinking that gigantic
smartwater.
There's dudes who have bladders like
mine who could just power through a
three hour podcasts and then this guys
like Tim Kennedy,
you know,
it's cool.
It's like,
you know,
we all learn.
We just,
we show,
we show that there's,
there's higher levels.
My fucking bladder bro.
It's like a duffle bag that you can
carry guns in.
It's large and it's durable and it gets
dirty and filled with liquid,
but don't worry about it.
I can hang in there.
Um,
what I was saying to Tim that's
important is I think everybody has this
idea that there's some guy out there
that's like jet Li that's like a perfect
person.
Some,
some character.
There's the beauty really in the
imperfection.
The beauty is in knowing that we're all
just these weird,
flawed creatures that are trying to
figure out.
It's not even that we're flawed.
It's just that we're,
we're dealing with an impossible amount
of variables that we're constantly
navigating.
And this idea that you should have
gotten it right.
It's not what it is.
It's the idea is that you learn from
what you get wrong and then that thing
you don't do the same way next time he
say,
you know what?
I made a mistake the last time I was in
a similar situation.
Now I know that,
and so now I'm going to power through
with the knowledge that I've accumulated
in my life from my past mistakes.
That's a,
that's a huge factor about being a
person of huge factor is that we're all
learning from each other.
And uh,
I said a lot of cool shit when you're
gone,
but that is a that.
But learning and learning from each
other is the whole reason why it's great
to have inspirational people to draw
from.
And I think that now there's never been
a time like this where you could just go
on youtube and you could be inspired for
24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
You could watch videos of guys pushing
through things.
Guys are doing fucking hundred mile
ultra marathons and just seeing people
talk about the things that inspire them
and what pushes them.
There's never been a time like this.
We just,
inspiration is available everywhere.
You look
in a whole bunch of different.
Not Everybody's inspired the same way,
you know,
like I think it's amazing to see a guy
that has nothing,
do something remarkable to come,
you know,
not the underdog,
but that has no resources that then
there's this guy in Austin,
Texas,
his,
he runs this running group called
Gilbert Gazelles and um,
the who to,
when the genocide that was occurring,
he has these burns on his body because
his family was murdered and he was piled
into this pile of bodies and set on
fire.
And once the militias,
I'm Ryan left from the Hutu in Tutus,
he got up and started running.
Then he went to the NCAA and started
running there and then he went to the
Olympics and now he runs.
He's an inspirational dude in Austin
that just tells people to run.
And he's one of the most remarkable
human beings.
And there's,
there's tons of people out there that
are so amazing and remarkable.
And you can,
if you just look,
you can find them.
And then that I,
I love latching onto people like that
and just trying to get into what's in
there and try to not,
I don't want to say steal it,
but I want some of that.
Yeah,
well you don't steal it because they
still have it.
Oh,
they'll always have it,
but yeah.
But you absorb some of it.
Yeah.
It's very important.
We,
we,
we surround ourselves with inspirational
people and become inspired.
Surround yourself with negative and your
life is going to be a wreck.
And that's a lot of people don't realize
that and they just try to work through
these negative constant life.
You've got to cut them off,
man.
You got to cut them off and keep moving
because they will hold you back.
There are crabs in that bucket and when
you try to reach the top of that bucket,
they will latch ahold of your little
crab legs and drag you down with them.
Data was so,
you know,
retrospectively my dad was so wise.
So when he's like,
no,
you don't want those guys around,
you know you're going to be who you
surround yourself with.
You know?
And it's like,
whatever,
that guy is,
cool,
Haley,
that guy,
you know,
and now I'm like,
God,
it's hard.
How did he know so early.
There's always gonna be people that
will.
But those people are also important
because you,
you learn,
you know,
you learn from watching them fuck their
lives up.
I've never done cocaine.
And one of the reasons why I never did
cocaine is because I grew up with a
buddy of mine who's cousin was selling
cocaine and I watched this guy fall
apart.
He,
they,
him and his girlfriend would just do
blow and they would hide out in their
place and they would,
they had this attic apartment and they
would just fucking watch tv all day and
they would shrink.
Like their fucking face was shrinking,
their body was shrinking.
The all they would do is do coke.
I don't even know if they ate,
you know?
And I watched this guy,
it was like a guy who got bit by a
vampire and became like this disease
thing.
And I went,
Whoa,
keep the fuck away from coke,
you know?
And I didn't have to do coke and go to
rehab and pull myself out,
you know,
I,
I lived 40 plus years of my life with no
desire to do coke.
Fuck that.
And so it's not always good.
You need losers.
You know,
losers are there too for a reason.
It's the whole world was filled with
inspirational winters.
Like how would you figure out where,
where do we begin?
If everybody's a fucking winner now you
got to see people who ring that bell,
right?
You got to see people who tap out quick.
You got to see a guy who tapped before
the choke is even sunk in.
Like,
what are you doing?
Types two taps to strikes.
Well,
you know,
sometimes GSP versus Matt Serra,
sometimes it's good to tap to strikes
because fights over go anywhere.
When the guys on top of you dropping
bombs and you're starting to see sparks
and the elevator doors closing,
do you think tap strikes is a bad idea?
I don't know if I have it in me.
I don't know.
Like right.
I'm not saying it's bad idea.
Maybe I should respect the guy that
smarter than I am,
you know,
like I'm kind of like an oak.
I'm big,
I'm strong and I'm dumb,
you know,
like I'm just,
I'm going to grow and I'm gonna do what
I do.
Um,
maybe I wish I was smart enough to tap
two strikes.
I don't think I am.
I just don't.
I don't think I have it in me to be
like,
okay,
I'm not going to get outta here.
I'm just going to quit.
I don't think there's any problem with
tablets,
trucks,
but I respect your viewpoint.
I know what you're saying.
And I think you'd probably have to have
that sort of mentality to be an elite
level competitor in something like mma
where that's not even an option in your
head.
And this guys don't tap,
you know,
a good fucking war machine.
You just gets choked out.
There's a lot of guys that just say,
I never tap.
I will go out.
I'll get my arm broken.
Fuck it.
I'm not tapping.
It's not in there.
Yeah,
it's not.
Look good.
John Jones,
we fought vittorio,
his arms completely,
hyper extended tap ladder,
got let it get completely popped
backwards and then won the fight.
Anyway,
[inaudible] is to,
before you go to special forces
selection,
there's this phase four guys out the
street called [inaudible] special
operations preparation course.
The only thing that is isn't a trigger.
They take like 400 dudes and they ended
up sending 80,
80 of them to selection the other 320 at
some point.
Either got broke or quit.
Um,
I remember seeing the Gong that you go
up and hit and it's like,
so longingly looking at that thing being
like,
that's the smart thing to do.
Like,
you know,
you have blisters on your feet that
you've injected stuff into so that you
can't say like your skin,
like glues back to what portion it
separated itself from,
you know,
like you've lost 20 pounds in the course
of 30 days and um,
and you're looking at that Gong and
you're like,
a smart person would go and hit that
goal,
you know?
And I watched guys go up and do it and I
was like,
that's,
that's a smart person probably I didn't
have it in me.
So I'm maybe I'm dumb.
I think that's my take.
I'm either like too dumb,
you know,
like there's a balance there and I think
we're kind of a green each other from,
with each other,
from different perspectives.
Well I think the,
you're,
you're being self deprecating.
When you calling yourself dumb,
it's not a dumb thing.
But if you wanted to be smart about the
amount of punishment that you endure,
yeah.
But if you wanted to build the highest
level of character and durability and
mental toughness possible,
then it would be dumb to hit that gun.
I don't know.
Because the benefits of not hitting that
Gong is what you are today.
I would have got a cup of coffee and a
hot breakfast.
You didn't.
I didn't get a cup coffee today.
And,
and have the knowledge that you didn't
hit that golf.
It's a good looking gong.
I could go back,
I might have.
You're a thick guy for 185 pounds.
Like your,
your built in a very,
you're very muscular weight class toward
my wife uses.
What do you,
what,
what do you walk around that before you
start your cut
to like day of cut?
No,
like what?
Like if you,
if you had a fight that was four months
from now and you don't have to worry
about your weight,
what are you going to work?
Way To?
Twenty to 20.
Wow.
And did you fight light heavyweight at
all?
Yeah,
I think at wcs heavyweight ifl is a
light heavyweight.
Middleweight and then I've stayed at
middleweight.
Wow.
So when you,
if you're walking around in the two
hundreds,
how do you navigate a weight cut to get
down to 185 pounds?
Because that is a big issue in mma is
that point of diminishing returns where
some guys like Anthony Rumble Johnson.
Perfect example.
God,
he's good at two.
Oh five.
Jesus Christ.
The kid was so fucking big in between
fights.
I see him walking around.
He was fighting at one 74.
Kevin Burns and I saw him like two
months later it was 2:30.
I go,
what the fuck are you?
He's a house.
He was bigger than,
or I mean he was just,
he was on inside mma would fade or,
and he was towering over them wider,
thicker.
You're like,
what is going on?
And then finally he gets his shit
together,
decides to come back as a light
heavyweight and dominate sill Davis at
two.
Oh five.
And you're like,
okay,
this kid was obviously past the point of
diminishing returns.
He was,
he was diminishing his own ability to
perform by cutting so much.
Wait,
what is that number?
It's,
I think it's different for every athlete
and person,
you know,
and um,
when I'm,
when I'm to 15 to 20,
I feel like I'm a juggernaut.
I never have training related injuries,
you know,
like I,
I'm running an extra three,
four percent body fat.
I'm just like all around healthier.
My brain's working right.
You know,
like my libido is good,
you know,
I'm sleeping very soundly,
all eight hours,
you know,
like things,
everything's great.
You know,
like when I'm down to like that,
that one 95,
one 93 precut type weight,
you know,
we're like that five percent body fat.
My brain's not firing on all cylinders,
you know,
like it's libidos rough.
You're training three,
four times a day.
Like just things suck.
I'm like,
everything hurts.
You get down to five percent body fat
when you're like one 95 [inaudible] are
you doing,
how are you measuring it?
A pinch test water stuff.
The water tanks and then um,
the calipers,
that's a lot that's really low and then
you're going to cut another 10 pounds.
Just water,
10 pounds of water.
I think our final cuts usually like
eight pounds of.
But you know,
you're like,
my body doesn't.
I don't think it even recognizes like
I'll,
I'll cut.
I fought Michael Bisbing us probably
two.
Oh five when I fought him,
you know,
I weighed in at one or one 86 the day
before,
you know,
and then 30 hours later,
I've been eating and drinking and
feeling fantastic.
Do you recruit for that?
How many apps do you use?
1,500
milliliters to 2000 leaders like the
greener.
I honestly don't know.
Fighters that don't.
Right.
And nowadays,
yeah,
pretty much everybody does.
Unless you're like a frankie edgar that
literally weighs in at what he fights
that maybe it was like pretty rare
weights in his pocket.
Yeah.
Frankie fought at 1:55
and weighed 1:55.
Liotta machita fought a two.
Oh three for the longest time.
And you know,
weighed in at two.
Oh,
three for 200,
five pound weight class.
But look how good he is at 1:45.
Better,
much better.
You know.
So the diminishing returns,
like it's different for everybody.
Um,
you know,
I'm 5:11,
I have a 73 inch reach.
There's no way I can hang with the tool
fibers that have 86 and teaches,
you know,
that are six foot four.
Um,
yeah,
it might be as strong as they are,
but I'm like,
uh,
like as Brian Stan calls me like a
squat,
a little hobbit,
angry hobbit,
sometimes troll endearingly.
He refers to me as these things,
but he's right and I just can't reach
them.
You know,
like John Jones can runs around the
cage,
you know,
jabs me to death and then when I tried
to like athletically explode in,
then he violates me with something
painful.
Yeah.
Do you ever
think about going one 70?
Is that possible?
Definitely possible.
Yeah.
We've um,
honestly had robbie lawler beat Johnny
Hendricks.
I always out I would cut to fight
Robbie.
Really?
Because you beat Robbie and strikeforce?
Yeah.
Do you,
um,
do you when you walk around at two?
Oh,
five or 2:20
rather.
Is it because you're lifting weights is
because you're doing a lot of.
Yeah,
yes.
Um,
I like,
I treat the annual cycle of like fight
camp,
post fight camp,
pre fight camp,
fight camp fight.
And I'm Kinda,
if you look at like a,
like an nfl player,
you know,
they have the pre season where there
they're trying to get their body strong
and healthy so that when they go into
the season they have everything that
they need to,
to perform during that season.
Um,
so like my pre fight camp,
like right now where I'm lifting
weights,
doing a high volume of work where I'm
working on like my,
my sparring stuff now is a lot more
drill oriented.
I'm not burning tons of calories
grappling or boxing or sparring,
kickboxing.
I'm lifting a lot of weights so my
body's responsibly like getting healthy,
big and strong.
Again,
I'm getting my technique better.
So when I move into that fight camp,
I have this mold of clay that's totally
healthy,
that can be shaped into what needs to be
shaped to be executed for,
for a particular fight.
So when you think about like 2:20
and the garlic rumble Johnson who used
to weigh somewhere around that even
heavier and get down to one 70 crazy.
If you were going to get down to one 70,
if Robbie lawler beat Johnny Hendricks,
how would you do that?
Would you cut out the weightlifting and
start doing like marathon running?
Like what would you do to get yourself
leaner?
Yeah.
Um,
what would it be leaner or would it be
like less muscle?
A little bit of both.
I definitely have to lose a little bit
of muscle to be able to.
And how would you do that?
By not lifting or
just changing the type of lifting that
I'm doing,
you know,
like I'm,
I'm not doing those three rep max is,
have dead lifted,
you know,
four or 500 pounds.
So what'd you do these days?
Yeah,
like right now.
absolutely unloving it,
you know,
it's like I did shrugs yesterday.
Just shrugged.
Well not,
not just drugs,
but I got to do shrugs as actually my
strength because I'm like,
can we do some curls?
You shut your mouth,
you know,
it's like,
like straps that you never allowed to
touch those.
And I was like looking at those,
but like how can I use some straps that
looks good and grab the bar and do some
more weight,
you know,
he's like,
no.
Now the point of departure is calm and
he's like,
come back to me Tim,
and we're not doing curls.
I'll let you do drugs.
But that's all you know,
like,
so straps being you don't do straub's
because you only want to lift with your
hands.
Can hold up.
What's the point?
Yeah.
I don't
ever use straps.
I,
I see people using straps and I,
I get it.
I get what you're doing.
What's use straps functionally though,
she'd be whatever you could carry with
your hands too.
Especially for a grappler,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So you would just start doing high reps
doing high volume a lot more speeds.
Like I think I think I'd have to be
faster to at one 70,
you know like watching these guys are
just like all over the place and you see
like Damien Maia when he dropped down to
one 70 and you know,
fought rick story and to see like the
difference in the,
just the,
the amount of physical strength that he
had over a guy who was used to fighting
at one 70.
It's a big leap.
Do you think there should be more weight
classes?
Yeah,
I do too.
I think the one 85 to 205.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That's 20 pounds.
There should be three champions in
between those weight classes or at least
to.
Yeah,
I mean if you look at a guy from,
I'll go all the way down from like 1:55,
two,
two.
Oh five.
You know you have 55,
70,
85.
You have four weight classes from 1:55
to two.
Oh five.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think it's crazy and I think that,
you know,
a lot of people say that boxing is
watered down by all the weight classes.
I think it's watered down by all the
titles,
but I don't think there's anything wrong
with having a welterweight class at 1:47
and then a junior middleweight at 1:54
and then the middle weighted one 66
pounds,
but you 1:54
and one slash 60 is fucking significant.
Six pounds and significant 20 pounds is
crazy and I just think that there's just
a,
a lot of fighters who are tweeners like
Diego Sanchez.
I think Diego should be fighting at one
65,
you know,
I think when he gets to 1:55,
I think he's to diminished you scrawny
when he fights at one 70.
He's a little soft,
these little little small for some of
those really big giant dudes.
I think I'm kind of between 85 and one
70,
like my shape,
my reach,
my height,
and you're like,
I would love there to be like a 180.
Yeah.
I really should be more of that in the
everything.
Those are the things that I would like
to use to change the,
the downward elbows and knees on the
ground and more weight class except a
lot of problems.
Dana,
can we go ahead and execute these things
that Joe and I have concurred on from
today's podcast?
Yes.
It's not even Dana.
It's the athletic commissions through.
That's what's really crazy is that it's
sanctioned by athletic commissions and
you really don't have that much
influence over athletic commissions.
Yeah.
Especially,
well now the Keith Kaiser's gone.
Maybe they have a little bit more,
but I don't know how much they listen.
I,
I wish they would listen about a few
things for certainly downward elbows and
certainly at least consider revamping
the scoring system and then adding
weight classes.
Um,
one of the things about weight cutting,
do you find that are an issue like the,
there's obviously an issue with injuries
and there's obviously an issue with
diminishing health.
Do you worry about the long term
repercussions
of like there was an article recently,
Jim Miller was talking about weight
cutting.
He's like,
I know I've taken years off my life
through weight cutting.
Do you worry about that?
I do.
The things that I am really conscious
about my brain,
you know,
when I'm cutting weight I like,
I love reading,
I love writing,
you know,
like even,
creative writing too.
Like I love.
Do you write a blog?
Do you keep a blog or anything?
Yeah,
for me.
Just for you?
Yeah.
You're going to publish it some day.
Maybe.
There are a couple of times where I
wrote a,
wrote some blogs when I was deployed,
um,
letters from a foreign land and I'm
like,
people love,
like I'm an okay writer,
I'm not the best like anyways,
everybody.
So worse credit,
um,
and when I'm cutting like my brain
doesn't work right?
Like I feel it.
And um,
and then when you're getting hit in the
head while you're cutting,
you know,
from guys like John Jones and Carlos
condit,
you know,
like,
life sucks,
your brain sucks.
So I'm like,
yeah,
I have my eyes are wide open that
there's,
you know,
physically going to be some
repercussions to me fighting,
you know,
for me,
jumping out of airplanes for like,
at what point do I say,
okay,
I'm not going to do this because it
hurts me in the long term.
You know,
like
you're 34.
Yeah.
Do you have a cutoff?
Do you have like an age where you're
like,
this is the age where I don't want to be
doing this anymore.
Definitely.
What you would tell you,
you can't tell me.
Okay.
But you have a number in your head where
you would like a goal to reach.
I love randy couture and Dan Henderson
and I had to get some of the.
They had send the greatest fights
towards the end of their careers.
I am not going to be fighting at 40,
you know,
I'm not gonna be fun
fighting my late thirties,
you know,
like,
Oh,
you told me the number then that's the
only you don't leave in five years ago
there.
Yeah.
You got a five year window then.
Wow.
Yeah.
No Way.
I got too much.
I want to do.
What do you want to do?
Um,
I want to change people's lives.
You know,
I want,
I want to be able to impart individual
responsibility.
People.
I want to save some animals.
I want to own a hudson more.
Um,
I want to make some awesome TV shows and
try to TV shows.
Uh,
so duck dynasty.
No,
I do not want to do duck dynasty at all
and I don't even think I've ever seen a
full episode,
but I haven't.
Maybe I've seen like three quarters of
an episode.
But you done lost your red neck from our
rear admiral.
Those guys took values that they wanted
to project and they figured out a
conduit to do it.
We might call them idiots and they have
horrible accents and they do stupid
things.
And um,
but they had a set of morals that they
try to convey and they found an avenue
to reach out millions of people,
you know,
like I want that platform because I have
some good things to say,
you know,
and I,
I think I want to have an
opportunity to make a difference.
Why don't you do a podcast,
start off with the podcast,
do a podcast now.
Be like one of the first mma guys mean
Brendan Schaub does one with Brian
Cowen.
But Brendan's kind of a meathead,
let's be honest.
He's a great guy.
Love Him.
But you're so like,
you're intimidating and smart.
Like,
how could I compete with the Joe
Roadblock as,
fuck,
I don't blow smoke up my ass.
I know what you're doing.
I'm not that smart.
You are?
Nope.
The argument with Joe because he doesn't
forget anything and he's deceivingly
smart.
I was like,
I'm aware of these things.
I definitely look dumber than I am for
sure.
But that's not saying much because they
look really fucking stupid.
I used that to my benefit as well.
It's like I'm an infantryman immigrant.
I'm an MMA fighter.
I'm dumb.
Talk Shit to me.
Go ahead.
For sure.
Yeah,
I've definitely.
I smoked a lot of weed.
I've got plenty of brain damage going
on.
Absolutely,
but I'm not nearly as dumb as I look.
I look way fucking dumber.
I think you'd be great on a podcast.
I think you and the beautiful thing
about a podcast is,
and I fucking swear to God,
everybody that comes on my podcast,
I.
You should have a podcast.
I'm like trying to give.
I don't know.
I don't believe.
It's not that I don't believe in
competitions.
I don't.
I have the exact opposite of a famine
mentality.
I think there's.
There's 300 million people out there,
everybody,
everybody could support everybody and
there's still plenty to go around.
I really believe that,
but obviously my bladder even kindled
can't handle the podcasts at this
length,
so we.
We've already discovered a limitation
to.
Well,
in your defense you have a one liter
smartwater and you've drank a big cup of
bulletproof coffee.
There's a lot of liquids in there and
it's also just stamina.
I just like,
I probably couldn't keep up with your
strength and conditioning program and
you can't keep up with my bladder
program.
My bladder is like a fucking,
like a leather Satchel.
Back in the old days,
you can make them at a buffalo skins
strong and durable.
Lasts a lifetime handed down your
grandchildren.
You could easily do a podcast dude.
And the beautiful thing about it is that
no one be able to tell you what to do.
You could,
no one would tell you what to say,
what to talk about.
You wouldn't have to converse with the
producers,
captivate enough people to.
Because I want that the access to the
audience,
you know,
to,
to influence lives,
you know,
would,
would my words have enough meaning,
um,
to draw in enough people?
Of course they would.
I hope so.
They were there doing that right now if
I,
right now millions of people are gonna
listen to this.
I jump out of an airplane,
you know,
into the water,
into the ocean with a whole bunch of
sharks and go swim with them.
Like people are going to tune into that.
But what if you get eaten?
I'll start.
This whole thing is fucked now,
but then I get out of the water and I
can talk to them.
You know,
there's 16 million people watched him
parachute out of this plane into shark
infested waters.
Oh,
you're out of your mind and wrote a
motorcycle up onto the beach.
Then I have them.
But you have them already,
man.
You don't have to do that.
Trust me.
You've already done enough that you're
qualified.
You're qualified,
legit,
bad ass.
The idea that you're going to parachute
into sharks and that's going to change.
Everybody will ask.
The guy's a fucking pussy.
The sharks.
Oh,
he's got me.
Let's sit down and listen to what tim
has to say.
I think that's just broke off there.
You are so powerful.
Joe Rogan,
chest broke his microphone just with Ron
was.
I'll just hold onto it till we're done.
Bear.
His microphone is made from a maid in a
foreign land where quality is not
valued.
You easily.
Dude could do a podcast easily without a
doubt.
And I think that these,
you do a lot of videos too with ranger
up,
right?
If you call them,
I call them that.
What was the one we did?
The Black Swan thing.
That is interpretive dance.
Can we.
Can we show that?
Yeah,
that's fine.
Pull it up.
What's the name of that?
I think it's Tim Kennedy Black Swan.
Pull up Tim Kennedy Black Swan.
And I'll try to fix this microphone
while,
uh,
while that's happening.
But the problem you're gonna have it,
was doing a television show is producers
because they're going to look at you and
they're going to try to put you in a
mold and they're going to try to get you
to do a bunch of fake shit.
They do fake shit man.
They fake shit.
I had a problem with fake shit on my
Scifi show.
They faked a bunch of shit and I didn't
find out about it until it was aired.
And I came on the podcast and I
apologized and I didn't know and it was
a huge fucking problem.
And that's,
that was on a show called Joe Rogan
questions.
Everything like I'm trying to find the
truth about these things and their
instinct is still the fake shit and to
put fake shit in that you don't know
about that.
It's fucking horrible,
very malleable.
You're like,
no,
you're not.
That's why podcasts is perfect.
You do.
You have a very unique vision and your
unique vision is qualified by your
unique life experiences.
Any Hollywood douche bag is not going to
understand that and they're going to try
to mold you and what they think could be
more profitable for the network,
but they would also have to sleep at
night and they'd be scared of what I
could do to them once they go to bed,
but they wouldn't.
They live in gated communities and they
hire people to keep an eye out for you.
Is this it?
Here?
Play that and I'll fix this thing.
Hello and welcome to masterpiece theater
is a scene from black swan performed by
MMA fighter and special forces operator,
Tim Kennedy.
I had the craziest dream last night
about a boy who was turned into a swan
whom falls for the wrong guy and he
kills himself.
For the folks who are not watching this,
please watch this.
Go to youtube.
What compelled you to do this?
So the,
the movie Black Swan,
obviously.
Well,
Natalie Portman.
Beautiful.
She is beautiful.
And uh,
my mom used to make us take dancing
lessons.
So there,
as you can see,
there's some skill here.
This is,
you just can't do this stuff.
Whatever.
That is scary.
I'm your mom made you take dance and
your dad made you take martial arts.
Interesting cooking classes with my mom
cooking class.
Have Hunting with my dad.
Um,
that makes a balanced person that's like
I'm Yamamoto.
Musashi's book of five rings,
you know,
he believed that every button should,
every warrior should also be well versed
in poetry and calligraphy and art.
Yeah.
It wasn't by choice,
just like,
yeah,
let's go to ballroom dancing and learn
how to swing ballroom dance.
Oh yeah.
She got them all out of probably moved
out.
I was like 11.
I didn't have a chance to find someone
to take the motivation was I'm having
fun.
You know,
like you,
you can't,
um,
if you don't enjoy and have fun in life
and be able to laugh at yourself and put
on like a Tutu and dance around,
you know,
like,
like a Beautiful Fairy Butterfly Swan,
both the black and white version and be
able to understand what the transition
the metamorphosis from the black to
White Swan.
It's scary,
scary process.
It is.
Once you understand that about yourself,
there's really nothing more frightening,
um,
that you could do in the rest of your
life.
If I was that guy from.
What is that show inside the actors
studio?
Is that analogous to your transition as
a fighter?
I really,
really try to personify that.
You the Black Swan or the white swan
when you fight.
It's in me,
it's,
it's the journey to the Black Swan.
I'm neither,
you know,
it's like the scary down the rabbit
hole.
Like I took the blue pill and now I'm
becoming the Black Swan and there's
violent,
scary things on the way there and that
that's,
that's where I try to fight that is on
the journey to the black school.
Is that why you come out to the rooster
now?
I come out to the rooster because it's
bad ass song.
It is a bad ass song.
And roosters like the fight they do like
to fight,
but the songs about Vietnam,
it's about Vietnam vets.
The hundred and first they used to call
the tail gunner or the machine gunners.
The rooster on the team.
Is that allison chains?
Yeah.
So like POW,
mia,
Vietnam vets,
all of them.
That song,
the song was written by the bleaching or
about his father who are disenchanted.
They grew apart and he kind of resented
him for being in the war and then he
kind of had revelation that it was like
he had to.
He didn't have a choice.
He drafted.
So he wrote that song to,
to connect,
reconnect with his father who was a
Vietnam vet.
So that,
that song has a lot of meaning to me and
my community,
you know,
veterans.
So everybody walk out of that Song,
man.
There's like,
there's not like,
I feel like there's nothing you could.
You could hit me with a freight train
and I wouldn't care.
Grab portions of my body and try to keep
fighting.
It's a great fucking song for you,
man.
There's certain songs that just sort of,
you hear that song and you know,
that guy's fighting like there's a
country board can survive when Matt
Hughes fights,
you know,
there's just no getting around it.
Stranglehold.
When Benevidez fights,
Joseph Benevidez fights comes out to Ted
nugent's trying to hold,
which is a great fucking song for him.
You know,
it's just,
there's certain songs that just persona
fly a fighter that's a,
that's a good one for you,
man.
I'll have it forever.
That's my song.
Do they give you any pressure about
songs?
Did they like,
you have to approve it because I know
I'm Uriah Faber try,
you know,
he always comes out to California love.
But uh,
he wanted to do going back to Cali and
uh,
they wouldn't let them do it.
I don't think it's like the UFC.
I'm a,
I'm not sure to them that they have to
get rights to use that music in the
production.
And I have no idea how legally that that
occurs.
So sometimes they have a list of what
you're allowed to do,
you know,
there are some fight promotions were
like,
all right,
submit your,
your song that you want to walk out to
two weeks before and we'll see if we
can,
if it's approved or if we can get
approval.
Um,
you know,
it's,
I dunno,
I have no idea how it works,
but thank God I can walk out to rooster
because I'd be really sad if I couldn't.
Yeah,
it's perfect for you.
Do.
I'm glad that you have an exit strategy
because there are a lot of fighters that
don't.
And the saddest thing to me is a guy who
looks at fighting as everything like
that is all they're capable of.
That is all they're ever going to be.
They don't know what to do next and they
get out of it and they have this thing
where they,
they,
they're,
they're diminished.
Like you could see their aura is
diminished if you believe in Aras,
but whoever they are like seems less
when you were around them then who they
were when they were competing.
Yeah,
it's true.
There's nothing more tragic than seeing
the guy that blood and sweat for your
entertainment and at the end of his
career,
you know,
he wasn't smart,
he didn't do things,
you know,
how he should have.
And then at the end of his career he has
nothing,
you know,
he's fought 20 fights,
he's broken physically and mentally,
you know,
there there's nothing left in him and he
has no resources to continue his life.
You know,
like I have,
I've ranger up,
you know,
that accompany that I'm intimately part
of,
you know,
I've great relationships with partners
that are going to go outside of the.
When I'm done fighting that are going to
be part of whatever TV's series that I'm
in,
but it breaks my heart.
Seeing these guys that,
you know,
at the end of the careers they have
nothing and you're just like,
yeah,
yeah.
It breaks my heart too.
And it,
I've,
I've seen it so many times that it just
drives me fucking nuts,
man.
It,
it,
it just,
it drives me nuts.
I almost want to like grab them in the
middle when they're peaking and go,
listen man,
this is beautiful,
but it ain't gonna last.
You've got to have something else.
You got to have something that you have
as much passion for as you do this.
Maybe that's one area where you have an
advantage in that you've been in so many
life or death struggles,
firefights being deployed overseas,
seeing life and death and your
perspective as far broader than a person
who's just been an athlete,
just been an athlete that is sought
glory and believes that that is the end
all.
Be All.
Maybe,
you know,
I,
I definitely have this perspective that,
you know,
we have,
we have a shelf life as an athlete and
it's short.
It's this window of opportunity that if
you don't capitalize on it,
you know,
it's common,
it's gone.
And um,
most people don't understand that,
you know,
we have this,
this,
this window to,
to earn our earning potential is small
for an athlete.
You know,
like,
I never had that.
This is something that I wanted to do.
I wanted to be champion.
I want to be champion and that's what
I'm trying to achieve in this window,
not financial gain or like,
like if I don't achieve it in that
window,
I can move on to the next thing to then
achieve the next thing that I'm trying
to do.
But uh,
these guys that go in there,
they,
the Mike Tyson is a perfect example of
where,
you know,
he literally pissed it all away and then
at the end of,
you know,
what happened to $230 million dollars
that you had,
you're bankrupt.
Crazy.
Did he to stash away 10 can live off 10
for a long fucking time,
man.
Just dig tense.
Blow to 20.
Yeah.
It's crazy when you see those stories,
but it's almost like the Hubris that
allows you to be a combat athlete in a
lot of ways.
This idea that I'm different or like
your idea,
you're going to fucking parachute into
sharks.
You're going to be fine.
I'll be fine.
You know,
I'm not like that poor fuck.
That was a triathlon training off the
course of,
uh,
off the coast of San Diego and got
bitten in half in front of his friends.
That happens.
Pro happens.
Anybody gets in there.
It's a bad world.
Oceans a bad place.
I don't like it at all.
Sharks are beautiful.
Yeah,
they're beautiful when you have a
delayed over a grill.
Delicious as well.
Um,
one 70.
This is the last question.
Do you think that your best chance for
our title would be at one 70?
No,
I think I'm close either.
Next fight.
You know,
who Joe Silva gives me is,
you know,
fits the VB Vitor Belfort,
jock raise,
you know that,
that puts me right there.
You know,
I'm number six.
I be number two.
Three guy.
That's the title fight.
You know,
foreign owned The you ob for?
No,
in the UFC.
Just beating in a title.
Eliminated my last two fights.
Have been five rounder,
main events,
you know,
how can you not say so am I,
I'm potentially one fight away.
Um,
you know,
Mark Munoz and move saucier fighting.
Could I potentially be fighting the
winner of that fight?
You know,
that's,
that's definitely in the room too.
And if that's the case then maybe I am
too fights away.
If I cut down to one 70,
I don't think that.
Let me fight for the title,
you know,
like I'd still be one fight away,
maybe two.
So no,
I don't think I'd be any closer.
Would,
uh,
physically the physicality of like me
being a bigger one 70 than a lot of guys
stronger than one 70.
Yes,
there'd be benefits there.
But again,
diminishing returns.
Like what am I giving up for that in
exchange for.
Do you look at the window that you have?
I mean we've established that you think
you have a five year window.
I know you don't want to give up the
number,
but you did.
Do you do you look at that and say,
well,
if I do get to a title shot at one,
a five,
how much time would I have left to work
myself up to a title shot at one 70?
Or would I regroup and try again at one
85 if I wasn't successful?
The first attempt,
like do you have those thoughts in your
head or do you just think about next
fight?
No def.
I definitely have those thoughts in my
head.
I love having the five meter target.
That's the super close thing that I'm
looking at that I'm saying this is the
goal that I'm trying to achieve.
I'm trying to get a perfect group in
right here,
you know,
that's that potential next opponent,
that's that guy that drank two,
three,
four so I can get a title eliminator
type fight.
But then I see the,
the long road.
We're like,
okay,
I fight,
not fight.
I,
when I'm fighting for the title and I
lose the title,
can I kind of Chalcedon in it and talked
my way into another title fight in a
different way.
Class,
you know?
Um,
Chael Sonnen is an interesting way to
describe it because that's what a lot of
people are doing now.
Yeah.
Duty when you,
when you,
when your name has become a verb.
Like,
dude,
he just totally got chills sewn in.
Sells a master wordsmith.
He really is.
You did a great fucking job chels
sending it with this Michael bisping
fight though.
Both of you did.
I mean it,
it got interesting and I was very happy
that you guys sort of sorted it out
inside the octagon and you both gave
each other a lot of respect.
But God damn,
there was a lot going back and forth
between you two.
Yeah.
We're like,
we're never going to be friends.
No.
But when you like when you hit,
I hit him so hard.
So like I,
I,
it had the same performance that in,
in strikes landed in percentage that Jon
Jones to texture it did as I did to car
being like,
that's I hit that guy that many times.
You have blasted him with some hard
shots.
He took them,
he took them,
you know,
like I know how hard I hit.
I put guys down to the gym with way less
and I'm wearing four ounce gloves and
Michael Bisping was like,
Hey,
I'm here for 25 minutes.
You're not going to put me away as like,
how can you not respect a guy for that?
Now he's,
uh,
he's definitely a tough dude.
He's very,
very determined.
He's a,
he's also a,
you've got to give it up for them,
for mental toughness.
Just not even considering retiring.
The fact he's fucked his eye up to eye
surgeries.
Not even,
it was just,
it's just a thing I'm going to pull
aside,
get back into the gym who will come and
striking,
you know,
he's,
he's tough as they come.
He's a born fighter.
I mean,
really,
that's what he's supposed to be doing.
Is he the personification of our
nightmare of two,
three fights,
let's say,
loses two more fights.
That is the end of his career.
Um,
you know,
he,
his,
he's,
he,
his eyes going to be permanently damaged
to the rest of his life,
you know,
like how much brain damage does he had
and how many fights and how many
sparring preparations for or fight has
he had.
Now he's done and he's out of the
limelight and he's broken,
you know,
does he have,
was he smart enough to prepare for that?
I think he was,
but you know,
he,
he is that example of,
you know,
key left everything in the cage and time
and time again at 24 minutes.
So the fifth round,
that dude was still trying to get up for
me.
You know,
like when the,
when the,
when the 32nd call was from our corners,
he's like started coming right at me
after I just dominated him for 24 and a
half minutes.
Yeah.
He wasn't given.
I'm still trying to win that fight.
What a great.
He's a tough dude.
No doubt about it.
He's got some serious problems.
He's got a real injury to his neck.
Affecting is a strength of his arm.
You know,
he's a,
he's as tough as they come.
You know,
he's definitely as tough as they come,
but I know what you're saying as far as
guys that accumulate injuries and then
they get to a certain point in time like
what is left.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that have done
less far,
far less,
you know,
less successful than him that their
bodies have given out along the way.
It's a fucking hurt game,
so the game and the hurt game is along
the way.
Just the amount of accumulation of
damage that you get in training.
Forget about.
That's what most casual fans just have
no idea.
You see little cuts,
a little bit of blood,
a little bit of sweat and the fight,
that's nothing,
you know,
like leading up to my 25 minute fight
with Michael Bisping like my sparring
partners were like Bubbleq Danielle and
Carlos condit when they're are peaking
for their fights and then they moved on
and then I had John Jones,
myself,
like this room full of dudes that are
the best in the world and if we're
sparring two times a week for seven,
six,
seven,
eight weeks,
you know,
like leading up to that fight,
and like we're hitting each other just
as hard there as we are in the cage,
you know,
because you have to put,
push yourself as far as you can in
training so that the best element of who
you are,
what you are occurs in the cage,
what do you,
how do you feel about that?
Like as far as like sparring hard,
do you think that you have to spar as
hard as you fight or do you think that
there's a way?
Like Robbie lawler famously said that he
doesn't really spar much as sitting.
Yeah.
He said he knows how to fight.
He said it's just about getting in shape
and working on his technique and I'm a
little ice bar way less than I used to.
You know,
like I,
I'm,
and on very rare occasions do I really
go all out.
But I think there are there times in a
fight
camp where both your coaches need to see
you and you need to see yourself when
you're,
when you're trying to do it all.
You know,
when,
when you're broken,
when you're hurt,
when you're tired,
you know,
and sometimes the only way to get there
is to push yourself to the limit and
they only put way to get there is man by
going after it.
And so you have to feel what it's like
to be inside that,
that,
that position to be inside that,
that position where you're just duking
it out at 100 percent.
There's no holding back.
You know what it's like to be exhausted.
You know what it's like to be strong,
you know what it's like to be hurt,
you know what it's like to bounce back
from being dominated in a,
in a training session.
Like there's no substitution for that
actual fight.
No,
no.
In grappling.
Like do I ever am I in a position for,
you know,
a guy for me to work on an escape of an
bar,
you know,
there's a thousand ways I could have
prevented ever getting there.
But I still have to see what it's like
to get out of it.
And the only way I'll ever see what it's
like to get out of it is a film actually
put in it.
So it's the same in fighting like,
um,
when I,
when I thought I had really hurt my hand
in,
uh,
in the first round and I sit down and I
come out the second round,
I just tanked,
you know,
like pain,
adrenaline dumps against,
against Mike,
you know,
I come back to the court at the end of
second round and they're like,
all right,
so you're gonna lose this fight if you
do that.
I was at the pits,
you know,
like my hands hurt.
I wasn't sure if I could throw my right
hand again.
Um,
but you through it?
Yeah.
What was wrong with it?
A broken.
It was broken,
but it's okay.
Now I have,
I have the brakes in the car that I'm
supposed to be wearing.
I'm just embarrassed.
What's broken on it?
The metacarpal and this,
uh,
this,
this right here.
How bad is it?
Broken through just a hairline fracture.
They said six weeks in a cast.
And I was like,
I can't handle a cast.
Me Sprays.
Just jumping the fucking ocean.
Have the sharks take care of it.
Yeah,
dude,
you're crazy man.
But that's why you do what you do.
Yeah.
Look,
we're out of time.
Tim Kennedy.
You're bad motherfucker.
This last very fun podcasts.
We've got to do it again and please do
one of your own man,
please.
You'd be awesome at it.
We'll see.
Please.
Thank you.
Follow Tim Online.
You can get ahold of them on twitter,
but be nice.
You fuck heads.
Don't be a dick.
Wad.
Alright.
Tim Kennedy,
MMA on twitter.
Do you have a website?
Yeah.
Tim Kennedy,
MMA,
facebook's,
Tim Kennedy,
mma.
Everything's instagram is Tim Kennedy,
It's Tim Kennedy,
MMA,
Tim Kennedy,
mma.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you very much brother.
That was a great time.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to one 800 flowers.com.
Go to one 800 flowers.com.
And enter the code word J R E or call
one 800 flowers and mentioned j r,
e Dot.
Get yourself 24.
Beautiful multicolored roses for just
$29.
Ninety nine.
And that is regularly 49 99.
So you will save yourself $20.
That offer is only good today.
It expires tomorrow,
which is Thursday,
May 8th.
So,
uh,
do that you have Fox and thank you.
One 800 flowers.
Thank you also to stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com,
chrome stamps.com
and use the code word j r e to get a
$110 bonus offer,
which includes a free digital scale and
up to $55 of free postage.
Save yourself the inconvenience of the
post office.
Print us postage directly from your home
computer folks.
Thanks also to on it.com.
Go to o n n I t use the code word Rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
we'll be back this weekend.
Most likely Brendan Schaub.
Bryan count and I are going to do a
podcast simultaneously while the UFC is
on,
on Saturday night.
And I think I have a podcast with Aubrey
this weekend to a lot of good shit
coming up.
A lot of good people,
much love to everybody.
Big Cast.